Das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch.
Ich denke, dass der Fußball an sich natürlich schon wunderbar erzählerisches Material hat. Das ist natürlich auch klar. Ich kann auch verstehen, dass man sagt, ich guck mir lieber 90 Minuten im Stadion an, als auf der Kinoleinwand. Aber andererseits, die größeren Überraschungsmomente sind inzwischen tatsächlich im Kino zu sehen. Um mal überrascht zu werden, was Tolles zu erleben und in Staun zu kommen, sollte man sich einen Fußballfilm angucken.
Ja, Überraschungen im Fußball gibt es vielleicht nur noch im Kinosaal oder vor dem Fernseher. Das wollen wir heute diskutieren im großen Tribünengespräch zum Thema Fußballfilme und Fußball im Film generell. Und damit Hallo und herzlich Willkommen hier im Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Mein Name ist Max Ackob-Ost, ich bin der Ed Genetzer bei Twitter und habe die große Ehre, dieses Gespräch hier zu moderieren mit zwei tollen Gästen. Deshalb begrüße ich bei mir jetzt gleich zum einen Ina Bargmann. Sie ist unter anderem in der Produktionsleitung beim 11mm-Fußballfilmfestival. Ina, ist das auch so dein Bezug zum Thema Fußballfilme?
Ja, also ich würde sagen, ich hatte schon immer so einen Bezug zu Filmen, war glaube ich das erste Mal im Kino, als ich fünf war. Und der Fußball kam dann auch dazu und die Verbindung von Fußball und Film war dann so, ist so eine Herzenssache für mich. Und so kam ich auch irgendwann zum 11mm-Fußballfestival.
Sehr schön, dass du hier mit dabei bist. Herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk.
Ja, danke für die Einladung.
Und ebenfalls mit dabei ist Birger Schmidt. Birger, erzähl uns mal, was ist denn deine Verbindung zum Thema Fußballfilme?
Es ist tatsächlich so, dass ich sowohl film- Und die Berlinale für mich tatsächlich immer der Grund war, nach Berlin zu ziehen. Und gleichzeitig die ersten Dinge, die ich in dieser Stadt gemacht habe auf Fußballspielen war. Einfach diese beiden Leidenschaften zusammenfügen können. Und ich bin sehr glücklich darüber und auch sehr erfreut, bei dir jetzt dabei zu sein.
Diese Freude ist beidseitig. Jetzt stellt sich aber die Frage, Ina, wahrscheinlich wettet ihr euch ja nicht die ganze Zeit in eurem Leben nur mit Fußballfilmen beschäftigen können. Was machst du denn sonst noch so?
Ja, ich habe das große Glück auch in meinem echten Leben sozusagen mit Fußball befasst zu sein. Auch zusammen mit Birgern. Ich arbeite beim Lernort Stadion e.V. wir machen politische Bildung mit Jugendlichen im Fußballstadion und der Lernort Stadion e.V. ist der Dachverband. Wir haben 20 Lernzentren in ganz Deutschland verteilt. Genau, also der Fußball begleitet mich durch mein gesamtes berufliches Leben im Moment.
Wir leben den Traum, Ina. Genau, und damit ist ja auch schon klargemacht, was Birger so nebenher noch macht. Ihr beide seid im Lernort aktiv. Das könnte vielleicht auch mal ein Thema für ein Tribünengespräch werden, aber ist jetzt nochmal eine andere Nummer. Das heißt, Birger, du hast auch geschafft, dass du nicht nur, du bist für den Film nach Berlin gezogen, hast dort gleich angefangen, Fußball zu spielen und das zieht sich jetzt so durch deine Biografie, diese beiden Themen.
Es ist wirklich verrückt, weil ich habe es nicht für möglich gehalten, dass man fern des Fußballplatzes mit dem Fußball auch seine Mitte verdienen kann. Und bei mir ist es tatsächlich inzwischen 25 Jahre so. Ich war zuerst in der gewaltpräventiven Arbeit im Fußballbereich zuständig und dann kamen die großen Themen Fußball und Bildung und Fußball und Kultur dazu. Also ja, Glück in der Nische gelandet zu sein.
Ja, so würde ich es auch sagen, ja, Glück in der Nische gelandet zu sein.
Das geht uns allen dreien so und deswegen haben wir auch die Möglichkeit und ihr die Expertise, dass wir über dieses große Thema Fußballfilme sprechen können. Bevor wir damit loslegen, möchte ich noch einen Dank an ein paar Unterstützerinnen und Unterstützer des Rasenfunks loswerden. In diesem Fall sind das Kasb4101, Eye2theX, Markus Janosik und Olaf. Sie alle unterstützen uns nicht nur, sondern haben sich auch registriert auf rasenfunk.de und deswegen weiß ich, dass ich sie mit diesen Namen, die sie sich da ausgesucht haben, danken kann. Ganz vielen herzlichen Dank für eure Unterstützung. Wer ebenfalls dazu beitragen möchte, dass der Rasenfunk auch finanziell im Bein steht und dass es hoffentlich bald auch mal ein Gästehonorar für so tolle Gäste wie Ina und Berger gibt, der kann uns finanziell unterstützen. Es reichen auch kleine Beträge. Sie summieren sich dann auf, ganz viele von euch machen das mit den kleinen Beträgen und irgendwann reicht es dann hoffentlich nicht nur für mich zum Leben, sondern auch eben dazu, dass wir den Gästen dann etwas abgeben können, was sie sehr verdient haben. Also guckt euch das an rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen. Aber dann lass uns gleich ins Thema reingehen. Ina, erste Frage, was ist denn eigentlich ein Fußballfilm? Ist es überhaupt richtig, dass ich diesen Begriff jetzt schon so häufig verwendet habe? Gibt es ihn, den Fußballfilm?
Also den Fußballfilm gibt es glaube ich nicht. Ein Fußballfilm kann tatsächlich alles sein, Fußballfilme können kurze Filme sein oder lange Filme. Es gibt auch wahnsinnig viele mittelange Filme, also die so zwischen 30 und 60 Minuten haben. Es umfasst alle Gattungen und Genres, also es gibt Spielfilme, Dokumentarfilme, Mockumentaries, Experimentalfilme, Dramas, Komödien, also es kann alles Mögliche sein, Liebesfilme, Krimis, Actionfilme. Wir haben schon alles gesehen, glaube ich, beim 11mm-Festival. Das einzige, was man wirklich sagen kann, was eine Bedingung ist dafür, dass man von einem Fußballfilm spricht, ist eben, dass Fußball als Leitmotiv oder zentrales Thema vorkommt. Also es reicht dann nicht, wenn einmal ein Protagonist irgendwie in einem Film den Ball durchs Bild schießt, sondern es muss eben wirklich zentral für den Film sein. Aber das heißt auch nicht, dass man immer nur Fußballs sieht, sondern manchmal ist eben Fußball ein ganz wichtiges Element für die Hauptpersonen oder sowas. Also es gibt wirklich, man kann nicht den einen Fußballfilm so festmachen.
Und das ist ja auch etwas Besonderes, glaube ich, dass es ein Motiv gibt, in das im Grunde alles rein interpretiert werden kann oder mit dem man quasi in filmerischer Art alles ausdrücken kann oder alle Facetten des Lebens ist. Ist damit der Fußball etwas Besonderes auch innerhalb der Filmgeschichte und der Filmografie oder gibt es da auch noch so andere Motive, die ähnlich besetzt sind?
Also wir befassen uns natürlich sehr viel mit Fußballfilmen, deswegen kann ich das jetzt zum Beispiel zu anderen Sportarten oder so gar nicht sagen. Aber es gibt natürlich auch andere Sportfilme, wo immer wieder der Sport eine Rolle spielt für die Hauptpersonen im Film. Aber für uns ist der Fußballfilm natürlich schon sehr einmalig und es werden auch immer mehr. Also wir hatten dieses Jahr beim Festival über 250 Einreichungen. Die neue Filme sind die in den letzten zwei oder drei Jahren entstanden sind. Also es war zu Beginn des Festivals wirklich anders.
Birger, wie hat sich denn das verändert und wie ist auch die Wahrnehmung des Themas Fußball in Filmen jetzt jenseits von unseren Fußballkreisen, also in der generellen Filmkritik zum Beispiel?
Ja, da kann man wirklich sagen, wir sind jetzt im 16. Jahr des Festivals und es gibt da ganz enorme Entwicklungsschübe. Als wir angefangen haben, damit 2004, standen wir wirklich immer einem Bereich gegenüber, dass zumindest Filmkritiker den Fußballfilm überhaupt nicht wahrgenommen haben oder schlecht gemacht haben. Und es war auch tatsächlich so, dass man gemerkt hat, dass beispielsweise die Inszenierung des fiktiven Fußballs nicht gelungen war, aber tatsächlich durch digitale Tricktechnik sich einiges weiterentwickelt hat, was die Qualität der einzelnen Spielfilme beispielsweise anging. Wir reden jetzt über einen Genre, das tatsächlich schon über 100 Jahre alt ist. Der erste Film ist 1911 gedreht worden, Harry the Footballer. Und das hat sich dann so weiterentwickelt, dass dann so in jeder Dekade, kann man sagen, gab es einen Film, der herausragte, bis es dann tatsächlich in den 2000ern für uns glücklicherweise sich ganz stark weiterentwickelt hat.
Aber was macht denn den Fußball so interessant für Regisseure, für Autoren, für diejenigen, die Filme produzieren? Was ist da deine Meinung zu?
Ich denke schon, dass der Fußball wirklich ganz herausragende Geschichten erzählen kann. Rund um Einzelpersonen, also sagen wir mal ein Spieler, ein Trainer im Mittelpunkt steht an der Geschichte. Das kann sowohl in einem Dokumentarfilm als auch in einem Spielfilm sein. Ein Fußballfilm hat Helden und zeigt große Niederlagen, große Siege. Von daher braucht man sich rund um die Drehbuchgestaltung gar nicht so eine große Sorge zu machen, bevor man einen Fußballfilm inszeniert. Das große Problem ist tatsächlich, dass am Anfang schon angesprochen wurde, wo mehr Drama stattfindet und mehr Überraschungen. Ist es tatsächlich im Stadion, wo ich bis zur 95. Minute warte, wer denn tatsächlich das Spiel gewinnt? Oder interessieren mich mehr die Geschichten, die drum herum erzählt werden, die Hintergründe? Ich denke, da hat der Film es immer mehr genutzt, auch Spannungsmomente so auf die Leimann zu bringen, dass rund um den Fußball hervorragende Geschichten erzählt werden können.
Es ist auch immer so eine Tatsache, dass man bei Dokumentarfilmen, wo man schon weiß, wie es eigentlich ausgeht, fiebert mit, weil die eben so gut gemacht sind und man fiebert wirklich bis zur letzten Minute und denkt, wird Arsene jetzt Meister oder nicht? Da ist sehr viel Spannung und der Fußball bietet eben sehr viel Emotionen. Das Kino bietet auch sehr viel Emotionen. Eigentlich ist es die perfekte Kombination, den Fußball und den Film zusammenzubringen.
Wenn der Fußballfilm nicht so gut ist, hat er trotzdem einen ganz besonderen Reiz. Das ist das, was Ina vorhin schon angesprochen hat. Dass so viele verschiedene Aspekte und Genres Platz finden unter dem großen Begriff Fußballfilm. Wir haben unheimlich tolle Filme, die aus Asien, Lateinamerika oder Afrika kommen, wo man sonst nie die Möglichkeit hätte, zu sehen, was dieser grandiose Sport auf diesen Kontinenten ausmacht. Das kann in kleinen Geschichten erzählt werden, das kann aber auch an großen Fußballveranstaltungen angeknüpft sein. Wenn wir eine Weltmeisterschaft haben oder eine Europameisterschaft, dann müssen wir uns die Gastgeberländer eher angucken, aber auch die 31 Länder, die sonst dabei sind.
Mit Fußballfilmen sind ja sowohl Dokumentationen als auch fiktive Ereignisse gemeint. Wie ist denn da die Aufteilung? Wie viele Fußballfilme gibt es in unseren jetzigen Zeiten, die einen dokumentarischen Charakter haben?
3 zu 1?
Ja, mit Sicherheit, würde ich sagen. Also in diesem Jahr haben wir tatsächlich relativ viele Spielfilme, nach meinem Gefühl. Also ich habe sie jetzt nicht gezählt, aber ich hatte das Gefühl, wir hatten mehr Spielfilme als sonst, aber ein Großteil tatsächlich. Also 60, 70 Prozent bestimmt Dokumentarfilme.
Ja, aber wenn man auch so zurückguckt auf die Fußballfilmgeschichte, dann ist es schon so, dass auch einige Spielfilme ganz wichtig und in den Kanon gehören, sozusagen, aber wir können es an unserem eigenen Festival so festmachen, dass wir den Festivalpreis 15 Mal vergeben haben und 14 Mal ging an einen Dokumentarfilm und das 15. Mal an eine Mockumentary, wo manche Leute auch ausgegangen sind und gedacht haben, sie haben einen Dokumentarfilm gesehen. Also das ist wirklich, wirklich ganz erstaunlich. Sprich nicht nur dafür, dass die Dokumentarfilme die wesentlich besseren gemacht sind, weil es gibt sehr, sehr gute Spielfilme, das muss man dazu sagen.
Es sind wahrscheinlich auch am Ende eigentlich die Spielfilme, die dann doch bekannter sind in der breiten Masse. Weil Dokumentarfilme haben es sowieso schwerer als Spielfilme wahrgenommen zu werden. Und es gibt dann ja eben tatsächlich immer mal so Spielfilme, die dann auch so Kassenschlager werden, die dann viele Leute gesehen haben.
Und wo würdet ihr dann zum Beispiel so einen Film, über den wir sicher später auch nochmal sprechen werden, wie das Wunder von Bern einordnen, der ja im Format des Spielfilms sich an einem realen Ereignis entlanghangelt?
Ja, das ist schon eine Mischform, die sehr häufig auch genutzt wird bei Fußballfilmen. Also, dass man wirklich Ereignisse aus der Fußballgeschichte heraus als Grundlage nimmt. Tatsächlich den historischen Anteil berücksichtigt zum Teil auch Bilder aus der Zeit in den Filmen. Das hat Sönke Wartmann bei Wunder von Bern nicht gemacht. Aber er hat zum ersten Mal gesagt, wir müssten so gut casten, dass nur Oberliga- und Regionalliga-Spieler als Schauspieler in Frage kommen. Das ist eine Sache, die sich wirklich auch erst in den letzten Jahren bei den Spielfilmen entwickelt hat. Dass das Mimische der Fußballer oder das Fußballerische der Schauspieler wesentlich besser geworden ist. Von daher auf deine Frage zurück, es ist ein natürlicher Spielfilm, aber durch diesen engen Bezug zur tatsächlichen Geschichte von 1954 in Bern ist es eine Mixtur.
Genau, aber bei uns im Programmheft zum Beispiel würde er als Spielfilm auftauchen und nicht als Dokumentarfilm.
Ja, gut klar, weil es ja auch nicht mit den echten Personen im Interviewstil usw. Aber ich finde diese Aufteilung, dieser Schwerpunkt auf der Dokumentation durchaus interessant. Und ich habe da so zwei Gedanken zu. Der erste Gedanke ist, zum einen faszinieren uns Dokumentationen deshalb, weil der Fußball eine in sich relativ verschlossene Welt ist. Und diese Dokumentationen erlauben uns einen oftmals sehr intimen Einblick hinter Dinge, die wir schon mitbekommen haben. Also wir alle wissen, Arsenal hat irgendwann die Saison gehabt, in der sie unbesiegt aus der Premier League Saison herausging. Oder wir wissen, wie die WM 2006 in Deutschland verlief. Aber dann nochmal zu sehen, wie das die beteiligten Protagonisten erlebt haben, hat eine besondere Faszination. Das könnte so eine Erklärung sein, warum Dokumentationen im Fußballbereich dann bei einem Fußball interessierten Publikum so gut ankommen. Der zweite Gedanke, den ich dazu habe, ist dann ein etwas kritischerer gegenüber dem Motiv des Fußballs. Vielleicht ist es in Spielfilmformat gesprochen, vielleicht auch manchmal ein bisschen zu simpel, weil im Grunde hat der Fußball immer den gleichen Spannungsbogen. Es geht um herauszufinden, wer ist Sieger und wer ist Verlierer. Und zwar gäbe es auch die Möglichkeit, viele Zwischentöne zu zeigen. Aber das, was die Menschen gewohnt sind, wenn sie mit dem Motiv des Fußballs konfrontiert werden, ist es, dass wir am Ende des Films oder am Ende des Spiels wissen, wer ist Sieger, wer ist Verlierer.
Ja, das ist ein tatsächliches Problem. Eine echte Spannung aufzubauen in einem Spielfilm lief häufig so, dass die Hauptspiele, die dann stattfinden, mit einem 0 zu 2, das ein 3 zu 2 wird, oder gerade ein 0 zu 5, das ein 6 zu 5 wird, dargestellt wurden und wo man dachte, oh nein, das habe ich jetzt schon dutzendmal gesehen, wie so ein Spiel kippen kann und wie eine Dramaturgie so aufgebaut wird. Und ich glaube, eine Schwierigkeit ist es auch, dass häufig, wenn wir jetzt erst mal auf dem Spielfilm bleiben, so aus einer Perspektive heraus der Film erzählt wird. Also eine Person oder eine Mannschaft im Mittelpunkt steht. Und das ist wirklich ein Nachteil gegenüber dem, was wir sonst beim Fußball haben. Dass wir uns wirklich beide Mannschaften angucken, auch wenn wir Fan eines Teams sind, aber beide zumindest auf einer Höhe dann erst mal am Anfang wahrnehmen. Und das waren immer so Punkte, die für mich auch immer schwierig waren, wenn ich früher Fußball-Fiction-Filme gesehen habe. Und dass sie zum Teil eben auch filmhandwerklich schwach gemacht waren.
Und wer schreibt die besseren Geschichten? Der echte Fußball oder der Spielfilm Fußball? Eine wichtige Frage, gerade für den Rasenfunk.
Ich würde sagen, der echte Fußball.
Ja, das ist, ich denke, naja gut, also wenn man so sagt, nenne die 20 besten Fußballspiele, die du gesehen hast, und nenne die besten 20 Spielfilme, die du gesehen hast, fällt die erste Kategorie tatsächlich leichter auszufüllen. Aber ich glaube schon, dass ein Fußballfilm auch herausragende Geschichten erzählt. Das ist so, wenn man denkt, wie viele schlechte Fußballspiele wir schon geguckt haben. Da hat man dann doch immer nur die absolut, was haben wir in der Saison, zehn Spiele, über die man im Nachhinein noch spricht.
Ja, ja, ja und über die Jahre verblassen die ja auch immer mehr. Also da bleiben dann ja wirklich nur einzelne Spiele. Und das ist ja bei Filmen genauso, da bleiben ja auch immer welche hängen. Aber natürlich ist es manchmal schwieriger, erst mal den Zugang zu kriegen, den Emotionalen zu einem Spielfilm, je nachdem, wie der einen auch abholt. Also mir fällt es oft leichter in der Dokumentation einfach, werde ich sofort abgeholt, weil ich eben auch diese Emotionen aus dem Stadion kenne und sofort mittendrin bin. Obwohl ich viele Filme sehe, geht mir das oft noch so bei Fußballspielfilmen, dass ich da so ein bisschen reinkommen muss.
Also ich habe das ganz besondere Glück, dass tatsächlich zwei Filme gedreht worden sind über die Mannschaft, die ich verehre und über den Spieler, den ich liebe. Und das war für mich vorher wirklich aufregend, weil ich Angst hatte, das kann nur danebengehen. Weil ich früher so leidenschaftlich die Spiele verfolgt habe. Das war der 1. FC Köln und Heinz Flohle, das war immer mein Idol und bei beiden Filmen ist es gelungen, die Zeit wieder mitzubringen und auch die Emotionen, die man hatte, wieder aufleben zu lassen. Also von daher hat ein Dokumentarfilm auch die Chance, Sachen zu konservieren, was ich sehr schön finde. Also wenn es um Spieler geht oder auch um Fußballereignisse. Da macht es einfach auch Spaß im Nachhinein, sich das nochmal anzugucken, was früher für Herzklopfen und Begeisterung gesorgt hat.
Aber das geht mir tatsächlich sogar auch so bei solchen Dokumentarfilmen, die jetzt nicht meine Mannschaft oder Erlebnisse betreffen, bei denen ich dabei war. Also da ist man sofort eben mittendrin und fiebert mit den absurdesten Mannschaften und Spielerinnen und Spielern plötzlich mit. Ja, je nachdem, wie sie gemacht sind eben, aber wir haben wirklich sehr, sehr gute Dokumentarfilme. Also ich will gar nicht gegen die Spielfilme sprechen, wir haben auch sehr gute Spielfilme. Ja, aber die Dokumentarfilme holen einen eben wirklich sofort rein, finde ich.
Na, es gibt eben einen emotionalen Referenzrahmen. Also dadurch, dass jeder, der sich für Fußball interessiert, einmal für ein Team mitgefiebert hat und das sowohl mal erlebt hat zu verlieren als auch zu gewinnen, kann man sich dann auch sofort in die Situation der Spieler und Spielerinnen reinversetzen. Viele von uns haben auch selber mal Fußball gespielt. Deswegen ist dieser Zugang ein direkter und vielleicht auch deswegen manchmal die Hemmschwelle bei Spielfilmen ein bisschen größer, sich darauf einzulassen, weil man das Gefühl hat, diese Geschichte, die dann gefühlt ist, die zusammengesetzt aus 20 unterschiedlichen Mannschaften und 20 unterschiedlichen Spielen, aber alles davon habe ich irgendwie schon mal gesehen. Also sowohl die Mannschaft, die 0 zu 4 aufholt, als auch die Mannschaft, die total unfair spielt, als auch die Mannschaft, die irgendwie so einen besonderen Spieler hat und alle sind ein Gurken, oder die Mannschaft, die irgendwie ein besonderes Ereignis zusammenschweißt und die dann against all odds irgendein Spiel oder Turnier gewinnt. Das hat quasi auch einen Bezugsrahmen, nimmt sich aber quasi die Frechheit heraus, jetzt fiktiv zu sein und deswegen begegnet man dem vielleicht als Fußballfan auch grundsätzlich etwas distanzierter, weil man eben das Gefühl hat, im Grunde habe ich das schon gesehen, aber ihr wollt mir das jetzt verkaufen, dass das in einer fiktiven Welt so passiert ist. Vielleicht kommt auch daher so diese grundsätzliche Distanz, die man manchmal bei manchen Spielfilmen mit dem Thema Fußball hat.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Das kann sehr gut sein. Es ist ja viel versucht worden, aber ich möchte mal jetzt doch nochmal die Lanze berechnen für die Spielfilme, beispielsweise Damned United, also ein Film von Tom Hopper aus dem Jahr 2009. Der schafft es wirklich, also am Werdegang von dem Trainer Brian Clough festzumachen, was Fußball ausmacht, also wie man wirklich eine Chance nutzen kann, über den Fußball wirklich sein Leben zu gestalten, auch zu einer Persönlichkeit zu werden im doppelten Sinne, also so, dass man populär wird, aber eben auch wächst als Person selbst, der Tag für Tag erst mit dem Amateurfußball und dann mit dem Profifußball zu tun hat. Und was der Film eben auch zeigt, ist, dass Niederlagen mit dazu gehören, also in entscheidenden Spielen und das macht es ja dann eben auch aus, dass man wirklich beide Seiten des Fußballs zeigen kann. Also wie öde wäre es, wenn wir jetzt einen Spielfilm hätten über den FC Bayern München in den letzten zehn Jahren oder so. Also das ist wirklich, wo ich denke, da fehlt die andere Seite dann auch. Okay, die scheinen immer in der Champions League aus, das ist eine andere Geschichte, aber ansonsten, so dieser Facettenreichtum, der da ist, wird tatsächlich immer, immer besser, sowohl im Dokumentarfilm als auch im Spielfilm festgehalten.
Ja und es gibt natürlich auch sehr, sehr viele Spielfilme, die jetzt gar nicht was nach erzählen, was real passiert ist, sondern die einfach den Fußball nutzen. Jetzt auch zum Beispiel dieses Jahr haben wir einen Film im Programm – Just Charlie, einfach Charlie heißt er – da geht es um einen Jungen, der eine Profikarriere gerade anstrebt, aber sich eigentlich viel mehr damit befasst, ob er nicht lieber ein Mädchen oder eine Frau werden will. Also da ist der Fußball sozusagen außen rum und es geht jetzt nicht irgendwie um eine große Mannschaft oder einen großen Trainer und das ist wirklich ein herausragender Film. Ich glaube, es muss irgendwie eben alles stimmig sein. Dann passt es auch mit den Fußballspielfilmen.
Ich erkenne da große Parallelen zum Thema Fußball in der Literatur, mit dem ich mich auch schon relativ intensiv auseinandergesetzt habe, weil das meine Magisterarbeit war im Fach Germanistik. Da habe ich mich mit dem Fußball in der deutschsprachigen Literatur nach der WM 2006 auseinandergesetzt. Es war so eine Frage, was ist nach dem Hype passiert? Diese Frage wollte ich beantworten und tollerweise hatte ich dann auch einen Prof. der gesagt hat, wenn sie das machen wollen, dann machen sie das einfach und kommen sie mal in zwei Monaten wieder und sagen sie mir, was sie bisher herausgefunden haben. Da ging es ja dann auch viel, um die Frage ein bisschen zu erörtern, welchen Platz hat eigentlich der Fußball in der Literatur?
Ich muss dich aber gleich fragen, magst du noch Fußballbücher lesen?
Tatsächlich habe ich mich damals dann so sehr da reingestürzt, dass ich danach eine sehr wohltuende Dürrephase erlebt habe. Ich weiß jetzt sehr viel schneller, ob ein Fußballbuch für mich geeignet ist oder nicht. Da komme ich nämlich zu dem, was Ina gerade angedeutet hat und worum sich so ein bisschen die Frage dreht. Der Fußball in der Literatur hatte ja auch nie den besten Rang. Das läuft in Teilen parallel zum Rang, den der Fußball in der Gesellschaft hatte. Also war er eben gesellschaftlich akzeptiert in welchen Kreisen und dann irgendwann hielt er Einzug in der Literatur. Gerade mit der WM 2006, deswegen ja auch dieses Thema, gab es dann eine absolute Hochphase an fußballerischen Motiven in der Literatur. Und die meisten Autoren haben den Fußball allerdings nur als Motiv für Gewinnen und Verlieren verwendet oder als Spannungsbogen. Und mir ist dann aufgefallen, dass diese Art von Fußballbüchern, die den Fußball als so verwendet, da gibt es zwar auch einige gute Ausnahmen, aber die meisten davon erscheinen einem relativ, auch aus literarischer Sicht heraus, nicht nur jetzt vom Punkt, ob sie mir gefallen haben, sind relativ plump. Also das ist quasi die erste Art und Weise, dieses Motiv zu verwenden. Und all diejenigen, die sich dem Fußball auf einer Ebene genährt haben, wo er vielleicht noch Handlungsrahmen ist oder vielleicht auch Metapher für irgendetwas Größeres, die aber etwas anderes hineinlegen, also wo es dann nicht mehr darum geht, wer ist Sieger, wer ist Verlierer oder ist etwas spannend und geht auf einen Höhepunkt zu. Und der Fußball ist dann quasi so die Metapher für die Spannung des anderen Handlungsstranges. Diejenigen, die was anderes reingelegt haben, die haben richtige Kleinoder erschaffen. Da gibt es richtig, richtig tolle Fußballbücher. Also eins, das ich mich total verliebt habe, ist leider nur antiquarisch zu haben, ist von Otto A. Böhmer, Wenn die Eintracht spielt. Der Fußball spielt eine ganz große Rolle, aber wird in einem komplett anderen Motiv gesehen. Da geht es um einen Protagonisten, dem im Grunde die Fähigkeit abhandengekommen ist, durch eine Krankheit Ordnung in seinem Gehirn zu schaffen. Und die Dinge, die ihm dann im Alltag noch Ordnung verschaffen, sind dann Fußballspiele. Also er kann sich quasi an jedes Spiel von der Eintracht erinnern, er kriegt aber seinen anderen Alltag nicht mehr so wirklich auf die Reihe. Das ist quasi der Startpunkt und dann gibt es aber eine Entwicklung innerhalb dieses Buches. Tolles Buch. Oder dann auch Schiedsrichter fertig ist ja auch so ein Beispiel, wo es zwar um einen Schiedsrichter geht und immer, wenn der Fußball da eine Rolle spielt, wird es ehrlich gesagt von der Metaphorik her etwas einfach gestrickt, aber alles außen herum ist richtig gut aufgeladen. Und da spielt dann der Fußball immer eine sekundäre Rolle, aber eine viel wertvollere. Und das ist die Erfahrung, die ich in der Literatur gemacht habe. Und vielleicht ist das im Film auch ähnlich.
Ich finde das eine hochinteressante Grundlage, weil wir haben vor fünf Jahren hatten wir einen Wettbewerb oder beziehungsweise wir selbst haben uns das gegönnt, den besten Fußballfilm aller Zeiten zu küren. Das 11mm-Team hat Filme vorsortiert und eine sehr prominent besetzte Fußball- und Filmebegeisterte Jury hat dann den besten Dokumentarfilm und Spielfilm aller Zeiten gewählt. Das nur als Impuls, weil wenn ich jetzt an diese Liste denke, die 20 besten Filme, die wir gezeigt haben, gibt es einen einzigen Film, der ein Fußballbuch als Vorlage hatte, wo man eigentlich denken müsste, Mensch, da ist so viel Stoff drin, das könnten wir umsetzen. Da kommen wir jetzt zu Nick Hornby, Fever Pitch und da muss ich sagen, dass ich sowohl das Buch als auch die Verfilmung sehr gelungen halte. Das Spannende ist das, was du eben auch angesprochen hast, es geht ja eigentlich da gar nicht so sehr um den Fußball speziell. Natürlich geht es darum, dass Arsenal das letzte Spiel bei Liverpool gewinnt, keine Frage. Aber es ist ja auch eine große Liebesgeschichte und tatsächlich der Umgang damit, wie man zwei große Leben und Leidenschaften nimmt, es geht ja tatsächlich um eine Paarbeziehung, als eben auch, wie gehe ich damit um, dass der Fußball mindestens auf der gleichen Ganghöhe ist, wie meine Freundin, das ist ja so die Grundlage bei dem Film, ist ganz hervorragend umgesetzt und das natürlich auch noch mit heiteren Mitteln, sodass man den Film immer wieder sehen kann, auch nach 20 Jahren noch. Und da ist tatsächlich ein Buch so gelungen umgesetzt worden, dass man sagen kann, gut, das gucke ich mir auch noch mal auf der Leinwand an.
Und was ich dann eben in der Literatur festgestellt habe, und da würde mich jetzt interessieren, ob das bei der Filmkritik ähnlich verlief, war, dass aufgrund der einfachen Motivstruktur des Fußballs und weil eben dann viele Schriftsteller auch bei diesem einfachen Motiv geblieben sind, sich der Fußball in der Literatur sehr schwer getan hat, jenseits von Peter Handke, der irgendwie mal die Angst des Tormanns mal im 11 Meter geschrieben hat, wo es aber ehrlich gesagt nicht um Fußball geht und wo das auch nur eine Metapher ist, die auch noch so ein bisschen umgedreht formuliert. Also na gut, vielleicht mache ich meine eigene Sendung zu Fußball und Literatur auch noch, da will ich mich jetzt nicht verlieren. Aber der Fußball hat sich da sehr schwer getan, auch von der Literaturkritik ernst genommen zu werden als Motivrahmen. Ist das im Film ähnlich gewesen, Ina?
Also ich glaube, dass es ähnlich ist, ohne dass ich jetzt sehr, sehr viele Kritiken gelesen hätte. Aber einfach so von meinem persönlichen Empfinden. Aber ich weiß gar nicht, ob das so sehr was mit der Machart an sich zu tun hat, als eher mit so einer generellen Ablehnung von Kulturschaffenden gegenüber Fußball. Also ich habe sehr viel im Kulturbereich gearbeitet, bevor ich mich dem Fußball mehr beruflich gewidmet habe. Und ich weiß, dass das immer so eine Außenseiterposition war. Also es war sehr wohltuend, zu 11mm zu kommen und mit Menschen zusammenzutreffen, die sowohl kulturinteressiert als auch Fußball interessiert sind. Also irgendwie wird das immer so ein bisschen auch als Gegenstück in der Kulturszene inszeniert, habe ich das Gefühl. Also der große Pöbel guckt Fußball und wir machen hier die Hochkultur. Das ist so ein bisschen mein Eindruck gewesen.
Das ist wirklich so, dass immer gesagt wurde, die Fußballfilme sind für ein Publikum produziert worden, die keine großen intellektuellen und ästhetischen Ansprüche haben.
Aber war das nicht zwischendurch anders? Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass gerade so Anfang der 2000er, auch die sogenannte Hochkultur, auf einmal haben sie alle noch mal von ihren Fußballerlebnissen gesprochen. Egal, ob das jetzt krass ist oder ob das irgendwelche Philosophen waren, die dann auf einmal Canetti ganz toll fanden, weil er eben auch diesen Fußballbezug in seiner persönlichen Biografie hatte. Ich hatte mal den Eindruck, es gab eine Zeit in Deutschland, wo es dann doch sehr en vogue war, auch in kulturellen Kreisen sich für Fußball zu interessieren. Man hat es halt auf eine etwas andere Art getan und sich vielleicht auch für andere Mannschaften interessiert.
Ja, klar. Also jetzt, wie du sagst, Anfang der 2000er, also FC. Delius, am Sonntag, an dem ich Fußballweltmeister wurde, ein Buch, das da wirklich auch im Föhton sehr stark besprochen wurde zu der Zeit und Walter Jens hat sich zu Wort gemeldet, Galeano, also es waren diverse Intellektuelle, die auf einmal rausgekommen sind. Ich würde auch sagen, das war so Ende der 90er, Anfang der 2000er, wo es auf einmal en vogue war. Und das hat aber noch nicht dazu beigetragen, dass die dann auch gesagt haben, ich würde mir gerne mal einen schönen Fußballfilm angucken. Das spannt es jetzt tatsächlich, wir haben beispielsweise in unserer Jury in diesem Jahr Gunter Gebauer zu sitzen. Für nächstes Jahr hat Klaus Theweleit schon zugesagt, dass er in der Jury sitzen wird. Also, dass Sportsoziologen und Intellektuelle inzwischen auch viel mehr Lust haben, den unterhaltsamen Teil dieses Bereichs mitzugestalten.
Aber interessant, wie sich das verändert hat. Also auch welche Rolle da tatsächlich die WM 2006 in Deutschland gespielt hat, wo man an diesem Thema – es war so groß, man kam nicht mehr vorbei. Und vor allem im Nachhinein – da findet auch so eine Ex-Post-Verklärung statt, zumindest war das in der Literaturwissenschaft so – es gab natürlich viele kulturelle Programme im Rahmen dieser Weltmeisterschaft. Und viele haben darauf hingearbeitet, du kamst am Thema Fußball nicht vorbei. Und als es dann im Nachhinein aber auch noch dazu geführt hatte, dass die Deutschen ihr eigenes Land anders wahrgenommen haben und auch das Gefühl hatten, in der Welt anders wahrgenommen zu werden, eben für die Art und Weise, wie dieses Turnier verlaufen war, dann fand Ex-Post nochmal so eine Verklärung der Zeit von vor der Weltmeisterschaft 2006 statt. Also, ich finde das wirklich interessant, dass es danach aber dann nicht mehr weiterging. Also, dass das so fast der Höhepunkt war, der auch kulturell in Auseinandersetzung mit dem Thema Fußball nicht auf Output bezogen, sondern auf Anerkennung und auf Platz, den er in feuilletons und so weiter bekommen hat. Und meinem Gefühl nach ist es danach dann relativ schnell wieder zurückgegangen.
Aber sie kamen eben auch nicht dran vorbei, weil es so präsent war. Man musste es ja aufnehmen in feuilletons, sonst war man ja irgendwie ein Außenseiter. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das wirklich dann alles so gewollt war, sondern einfach sozusagen der Mainstream es vorgegeben hat.
Da kann ich eine kleine Geschichte zu erzählen, weil wirklich das war sehr spannend, mit dem Inblick auf die Sache, also hier in Deutschland gelebt zu haben zur WM 2006 und wie das von außen wahrgenommen wurde. Es ist ja häufiger darüber gesprochen worden. Aber es war so, dass ich zu der Zeit mit meinem Freund Stefan Krankenhagen, der Professor für Popkultur ist in Hildesheim, einen gemeinsamen Lehrauftrag hatte zum Bereich Fußballbiografien und Fußballkulturen an der Humboldt-Uni. Und wir haben ihn bekommen, weil der Fachbereichsleiter, Professor Kaschuba, fußballbegeistert war und gesagt hat, Mensch, Jungs, macht mal was draus. Das ist ein hochinteressantes Thema, jetzt im Vorfeld zur Weltmeisterschaft. Wir haben eine ganz tolle Anzahl von Studierenden da gehabt, die wirklich begeistert, sich eigene Projekte diesbezüglich ausgeguckt haben. Einige der Leute sind immer noch Motoren bei 11mm und bei unserem Verein Bord und Spiele. Das war erstmal sehr schön. Es gab eine Abschlussarbeit und dann ist der Stefan Krankenhagen nach Norwegen gegangen an die Uni und hat dieses Thema, nämlich wie ist die WM 2006 im Ausland aufgenommen worden, dort auf die Tagesordnung gebracht. Das war wirklich sehr spannend. Ich durfte eine Woche lang in Seminaren mit norwegischen Studentinnen und Studenten zusammenarbeiten. Die haben eben gesagt, dass sie sowas auch noch nie erlebt haben. Sie waren so begeistert – nicht nur, dass die Sonne geschehen hat und die Leute gut gelaunt waren, sondern auch, was drumherum entstanden ist, dass sie das wahrgenommen haben. Sie haben gesagt, wir waren für eine Woche in einer deutschen Stadt und haben gesehen, was für Ausstellungen laufen, was für Musik gespielt wird, alles rund um den Fußball, dass Kultur in schönster Form rund um den Fußball stattgefunden hat. Ich glaube, dass wir drei auch immer noch davon profitieren, was da losgelöst wurde und dass man wirklich die Chance sehr gut genutzt hat, den Fußball von der anderen Seite zu zeigen. Ob nun in der Literatur oder im Film oder im Bereich Bildung, ich glaube, wir können gar nicht dankbar genug sein, was sich rund um diese WM ereignet hat.
Ja, das stimmt. Es trieb auch einige interessante Stiehlblüten. Damals hat man dann auch feststellen können, dass sich gerade das Feuilleton und auch die Philosophie sich darin übertroffen hat, noch krudere Dinge in den Fußball hinein zu interpretieren oder aus dem Fußball heraus zu interpretieren. Auf einmal stand der Fußball für alles. Bei einigen Themen, wie dass der Stadionbesuch sehr einem Gottesdienstbesuch ähnelt, da kann man noch viele Fakten, die dafür sprechen, nennen. Da gab es aber dann auch schon die eine oder andere Theorie und den einen oder anderen Essay über den Fußball, wo man das Gefühl hatte, da möchte jetzt auch jemand unbedingt noch mal beweisen, was noch alles im Fußball drinsteckt, was man alles erkennen kann. Aber so ist es halt vielleicht auch einfach im Kulturbetrieb. Wir übertreffen uns immer – also nicht wir, sondern der Kulturbetrieb – ich köre da ja nicht so wirklich dazu – übertrifft sich dann ja auch immer gerne in schlauen Gedanken und dann muss man immer noch mal einen draufsetzen. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall interessant, was dieses Turnier dahingehend für eine Rolle spielt. Und wie es sich danach dann wieder ein bisschen auf ein normales Level zurückgefahren hat, aber auf einem höheren… also der Rang der Fußballkultur spielt eine andere Rolle. Und auch der Fußball spielt ja eine andere Rolle in unserer Gesellschaft.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch beiden geht, aber man ist ja auch so ein bisschen ermüdet von dem, also von diesen Vergleichen, die die Politiker in diese Fußballer Sprache reinbringen und so.
Wir sind ja schon dankbar, wenn der Fußball mal mit dem Handball verglichen wird, wenn es wenigstens nicht um Atheismus im Fußball geht oder sowas.
Ja, aber eigentlich auch nicht. Die Handballer regen sich dann drüber auf. Wenn der Handball und der Fußball verglichen werden, auch zu Recht. Ja, genau. Der Fußball muss wir alles herhalten.
Jaja, es ist ja auch tatsächlich in großen Teilen…
Oh, da fällt mir gerade was ein. Wir haben auch mehrere Partnerfestivals. Im vergangenen Wochenende fand das Festival in Kopenhagen statt, wo ich vor Ort sein konnte. Es gab eine Diskussion an einem Tisch, warum der Frauenfußball nicht sehenswert ist. Also egal, ob man ihn nun im Stadion oder auf der Leinwand anguckt, es würde sich nicht lohnen, Frauenfußball spielen zu können. Das war das Statement eines der dort Sitzenden. Dann hat der dänische Kollege das ganz wunderbar gekontert, indem er gesagt hat, wenn ich alleine denke, welche Rolle der Frauenhandball in diesem Land gespielt hat. Also erfolgreich war sowohl vom Familienpublikum als auch vom Fachpublikum hervorragend aufgenommen worden. Die Hallen sind immer voll. Die dänische Mannschaft ist 1971 das erste Mal Weltmeister geworden. Es hat sich professioneller Frauenhandball manifestiert. Also das sind alles Dinge, die dafür gesprochen haben. Er sagte, dass der Fußball endlich mal verstehen soll, was für eine Chance er auch hat, dass Frauen eben auch ganz hervorragend diesen Sport betreiben. Und das fand ich klasse, jetzt wo ihr beide von dem Handball-Fußballvergleich gesprochen habt. Da kann der Handball tatsächlich dem Fußball nochmal einen schönen Weg weisen.
Ja, und die Kategorie Schön ist ja auch durchaus eine hinterfragbare. Also vermutlich hat die Bedeutung des Fußballs im kulturellen Betrieb auch damit zu tun, dass sich das Spiel als solches verändert hat. Also wenn man sich ein Spiel aus den 80ern, ein Spiel aus den 90ern anguckt, dann ist das eine andere Art des Fußballs und eine weniger schöne Art des Fußballs. Es ist jetzt ein fluideres Spiel, die Spieler sind technisch besser ausgebildet, es geht schneller von einem Tor zum anderen. Da ist vielleicht auch die WM 2006 so gut gelaufen, weil da hatten wir eben einfach auch einen Zinedine Zidane zum Beispiel, dann ja noch mit diesem tragischen Höhepunkt der roten Karte im Finale. Aber der steht ja so ein bisschen sinnbildlich dafür, wie der Fußball dann aussah. Und die Frage, die man aber eben stellen kann, ist, muss denn ein Sport immer nur schön sein, um auch kulturell wahrgenommen und verarbeitet zu werden? Und das ist ja in sublimierter Form hast du das ja in der Diskussion rund um Frauenfußball auch. Dass dann der Referenzrahmen dazu der Männerfußball ist, und dann ist der Frauenfußball etwas weniger schnell und in Teilen auch technisch nicht so anspruchsvoll wie der Männerfußball, was auch an den Strukturen des Frauenfußballs liegt. Gerade bei Turnieren sieht man das ja, wenn man dann Mannschaften aus anderen Ländern sieht, die eben ganz andere Voraussetzungen haben für den Fußball. Und dann wird diese Kategorie schön, aber in diesem Referenzrahmen Männerfußball gesehen, der schnell athletisch und technisch hochversiert ist und wird als nicht schön bezeichnet, was ja aber eigentlich mit der Definition von Schönheit nichts zu tun hat. Das sind so Gedanken, die ich bei solchen Diskussionen immer wieder habe, dass man ja eigentlich gar nicht sagen könnte, was ist eigentlich schön, und dass man aber dann einfach das eine als schön und gut und positiv darstellt, nämlich den Männerfußball, und dann alles andere, und das muss jetzt nicht nur der Frauenfußball sein, sondern auch ganz viele andere Sportarten, müssen dann aus dieser Sichtweise heraus weniger schön sein, weil sie ja nicht alles das erfüllen können, wie das eine Ideal, was man setzt.
Ja, es ist eben aber auch einfach bekloppt, das immer alles zu vergleichen. Also erstens ist schön natürlich auch eine sehr subjektive Wahrnehmung. Also meine Definition von schön ist sicher eine andere, als eure Definition von schön ist. Und ich meine auch ganz ehrlich, wie viele unschöne Männerfußballspiele gucken an. Ich habe sehr, sehr viele unschöne Männerfußballspiele schon gesehen. Und tatsächlich auch noch nicht so viele Frauenfußballfilme, nicht Filme, Spiele. Aber weniger, was damit zu tun hat, dass ich es nicht schön finde, sondern dass ich irgendwie nie so einen richtigen Bezug dazu hatte. Ich komme aus Bremen, habe meine Liebe zum SV Werder mit zehn Jahren ungefähr entwickelt. Und da gab es irgendwie einfach keine prominenten Frauenteams. Also ich hatte dazu keinen Bezug. Aber wir haben dieses Jahr ja auch einen Schwerpunkt Frauen im Fußball. Und wir haben einen ganz fantastischen Dokumentarfilm über die Mannschaft vom FC Rosengard, die eines der besten Frauenteams der Welt haben. Und ich habe diesen Film gesehen und ich war so begeistert und dachte danach, ich muss jetzt mal zum Frauenfußball gehen endlich, weil es so viel transportiert und so viel Begeisterung dabei ist. Ich meine, die haben Spielerinnen wie Marta da auf dem Platz stehen, die auch technisch wahnsinnig gut sind. Also ich finde, das ist kein haltbares Argument zu sagen, das ist nicht schön.
Finde ich genauso. Ich möchte noch mal zu dem schönen Begriff zwei Filme anführen. Also es gab ja zwei Werke, wo Spieler 90 Minuten lang portraitiert wurden, gezeigt wurden. Das ist von 1971, Fußball wie noch nie, George Best, von Helmut Koster damals gemacht, der Film. Und dann sind sie dann ein Portrait im 21. Jahrhundert aus dem Jahr 2006. Beide Spieler sind die ganze Zeit von mehreren Kameras aufgenommen worden. Während eines Spiels, damals bei Menio bzw. bei Real. Und das ist eine Sache, da würde ich mich total freuen, wenn das auch mal mit einer Fußballerin passieren würde. Einfach auch nochmal über die Ästhetik zu sprechen, weil ich denke, es ist zum Teil wirklich ein Hochgenuss zu sehen, wie auf dem Frauenfußballfeld – anders kann ich jetzt nicht ausdrücken – agiert wird. Und dass man sich auch da nochmal klarmacht, inwiefern es Chancen gibt, das ganze filmisch festzuhalten. Und Inas Beispiel ist wirklich hervorragend. Man müsste eigentlich jeden Fußballfan, egal wie er sonst aufgestellt ist, in diesen Film reinbringen, weil er es auch schafft, eine Mannschaft über ein Jahr lang hervorragend zu begleiten. Und da ist einem letztendlich auch das Geschlecht egal, weil es wirklich total spannend ist, was zwischen den Spielerinnen passiert, was im Management passiert und so weiter. Also Frauenfußball erzählt auch ganz tolle Geschichten.
Ja, und ist als Referenzrahmen manchmal auch noch näher an der eigenen Lebenswirklichkeit, weil das eben noch keine Multimillionäre sind mit ihrer eigenen Entourage, die sie umhegt und umpflegt, sondern weil sich der Alltag von Profifußballerinnen noch näher an dem Alltag befindet, den die meisten von uns da draußen selbst empfinden. Und deswegen ist es ja vielleicht auch noch mal doppelt spannend, sich damit zu befassen. Aber das ist ja auch ein interessanter Punkt, wie die Kultur dann rückstrahlt in die Beschäftigung mit dem Objekt Fußball. Also dass man dann eben so einen Film sieht und auf einmal noch mal den Frauenfußball mit anderen Augen sieht.
Ich wollte nur sagen, das ist ja sowieso, was Kino generell schafft. Es geht ja nicht nur um Fußballfilme, sondern Kino öffnet irgendwie die Augen für ganz fremde Welten. Und das schafft natürlich der Fußballfilm genauso. Ob es dann ein Film über Frauen ist oder ein Film über eine Mannschaft auf Sansibar oder so. Man erlebt irgendwie ganz fremde Welten und öffnet seine Augen und seinen Kopf für neue Dinge.
Genau, und diese Augen öffnen, das wollen wir jetzt auch machen. Ihr habt das auch schon perfekt gemacht, dass ihr meinen herum mehr anderen in irgendwelchen philosophisch-kulturellen Fragen immer wieder zum Thema Fußballfilm zurückgebracht habt. Ihr wart der bessere Moderator in den letzten 20 Minuten als ich. Und jetzt wollen wir dann auch in das Thema einsteigen. Wir wollen jetzt dann mal über die Geschichte des Fußballfilms sprechen. Das würde mich sehr interessieren. Birger, sag mir mal, was war denn der erste Fußballfilm?
Ui, das war also die erste – ich muss so sagen – die erste filmische Fußballberichterstattung. Das war ein Bericht über das Spiel Blackburn Rovers gegen West Bromwich Albion im Jahr 1898. Und der erste Film war dann Harry the Footballer aus dem Jahr 1911. Der hatte tatsächlich schon eine richtige Story. Das war ein Spielfilm. Es ging um einen entführten Torwart, der es rechtzeitig zum Spielbeginn schafft, sich zu befreien bzw. befreit zu werden. Um sieben Minuten. Das war ein Stummfilm, ja. Genau. Zwei weitere große Stummfilme sind verrückterweise in 1927 entstanden. Da haben wir einerseits Die Elf Teufel mit Schauspielern, die ich noch nachklingen höre aus den Erzählungen meiner Großeltern. Also Gustav Fröhlich, Willy Forst und Eveline Holt. Das waren wirklich große Filmstars aus der Ufer-Stummfilmzeit, die in diesem Fußballfilm mitgespielt haben. Es war eine Liebesgeschichte, die dargestellt wurde. Eine Frau zwischen zwei hervorragenden Kickern. Und tatsächlich auch mit erotischem Schwerpunkt, kann man sagen. Also für die Zeit wirklich ganz enorm. Wir haben den Film zwar einmal bei uns auf dem Festival präsentiert mit Live-Musik und ganz hervorragend gespielt. Und der andere Film, über den spricht Ina gleich, ist der König der Mittelstürmer.
Genau, auch den haben wir schon gezeigt vor zwei, drei Jahren beim Festival. Weil das schön ist, in unserem Festivalkino, dem Babylon in Berlin, gibt es eine Stumpe im Orgel. Also die können da wirklich Live-Begleitung machen. Sehr eindrücklich machen die jeden Samstag auch nicht nur mit Fußballfilmen. Genau, und der König der Mittelstürmer. Ich musste gestern leider feststellen, dass es eine Hommage an einen HSV-Spieler ist. Trotzdem ein schöner Film. Auch aus dem Jahr 1927 geht es um einen Fußballspieler, der sich gegen den Willen seines Vaters, dem Fußball, widmet. Der Vater ist Geschäftsmann. Die Firma steht aber so ein bisschen vor dem Bankrott. Dann kommt eine schöne Frau aus Amerika, die die Firma retten soll. Die beiden verlieben sich. Also es ist eben auch dann so eine Art Liebesgeschichte. Und am Ende darf er natürlich noch im entscheidenden Spiel das Tor schießen. Ja, tollhard war der Spieler. Und es war eben auch, glaube ich, dass der Fußball in den 1920er-Jahren grundsätzlich auch in der Gesellschaft immer mehr ankam. Also ich glaube, es gehört sich auch, dass da dann die Entwicklung des Fußballfilms anfing. Weil sich ja auch immer mit gesellschaftlich relevanten Themen auseinandersetzt.
Dann gehe ich ein bisschen weiter. Wir wollen ja nicht zu sehr ins Detail gehen, aber es gab dann nochmal zwei ganz großartige Filme vor dem Krieg bzw. tatsächlich dann auch in der Zeit des Zweiten Weltkrieges. Das ist einerseits ein englischer Film, ein Spielfilm wiederum The Arsenal Stadium Mystery von 1939. Wo wirklich bis dahin seltener Formen und vielleicht auch bis heute die Fußballer mit so einer großen Begeisterung sich als Schauspieler zeigen. Und es geht um einen gegnerischen Torwart, also es geht einerseits um Arsenal und der Torwart der gegnerischen Mannschaft wird in der Halbzeitpause vergiftet. Und es ist wirklich ein ganz hervorragender Krimi, der sich drum herum aufbaut. Das sind Live-Szenen, also aus einem tatsächlichen Arsenal-Spiel in dem Film verarbeitet. Und wer irgendwie die Chance hat, an diesen Film zu kommen, sollte ihn angucken.
Für mich einer der besten Fußballfilme überhaupt. Und mit den damaligen Spielern des FC Arsenal, die waren dann auch der Cast dieses Spiels.
Das war das Tolle. Der Cast war gemischt. Ich stelle es mir so vor, dass sechs Schauspieler und fünf Fußballspieler auf dem Feld waren. Oder umgekehrt. Das war ein Versuch, der überaus gut gelungen ist. Und das enorme war auch noch, dass der Stadionsprecher eine Rolle des Erzählers eingenommen hat in diesem Film. Also wirklich, man war schon sehr experimentell unterwegs.
Also hier sprechen wir dann auch nicht mehr über einen Stummfilm, sondern der war dann auch schon mit Ton unterlegt.
Und 1942 gab es dann in Deutschland tatsächlich einen ganz herausragenden Film, das große Spiel. Wiederum mit zwei überaus bekannten Schauspieler, René Deltgen und Gustav Knuth, waren damals in der Hauptrolle. Und das Interessante dort war, dass der Perberger tatsächlich als Berater des Films agiert hat. Und natürlich spielte 1942 auch die ideologische Sicht eine Rolle, aber man kann den Film trotzdem sehr gut sehen. Es ist also keine Nazi-Verherrlichung oder ähnliches. Es geht tatsächlich auch dort um eine Liebesgeschichte und um das große Endspiel. Zu der Zeit waren Rapid Wien gegen Schalke im tatsächlichen Endspiel, das damals im Berliner Olympiastadion stattgefunden hat, gegeneinander gespielt und im Film endete das Spiel so mit der Torfolge 0-2-3-2. Das hat Sepp Herberger dann ja irgendwann nochmal erlebt. Und das tatsächliche Endspiel endete 0-3-4-3. Also Rapid Wien hat Schalke 4-3 geschlagen. Von daher war dann tatsächlich die reale Welt noch spannender oder noch verrückter.
Aber gewinnt auch im Film dann Rapid Wien oder gewinnt da Schalke? Und das ist vermutlich auch kein Zufall, dass wir in Zeiten des Kriegs dann da nochmal zwei so wichtige Fußballfilme erleben, weil es ein unbelastetes Motiv ist. Also sowohl aus Seiten der Regierenden, dass man im Fußball damit ein Thema behandelt, was die Leute unterhält und gleichzeitig aber auch für die eigenen Zwecke genutzt werden kann. Auch wenn du sagst, es war jetzt kein Propagandastreifen, das große Spiel. Und auf der anderen Seite für die Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer, dass man eben mal kurz im Sinne des Eskapismus aus dem Kriegsalltag rauskommt und sich mit einem anderen Thema befassen kann.
Auf jeden Fall. Und zynischer und tragischerweise galt das auch für Akteure des Films. Das ist ähnlich wie bei der Feuerzangenbohle. Dass dort Schauspieler wirklich nur für die Dreharbeiten von der Front zurückgeholt worden sind und dann zum Teil die Premiere des Films nicht mehr erleben konnten, weil sie gestorben sind im Krieg. Ist es so, dass da eben auch Spieler, nachdem sie – ich rede jetzt von den Fußballspielern – nachdem sie vor der Kamera agiert haben, zurück an die Front beordert wurden? So muss man den zeitlichen Rahmen sehen und dementsprechend noch mehr schlucken, wenn man sieht, dass dieser Film auch so eine Leichtigkeit transportieren soll. Das ist schon grotesk zum Teil, was dann tatsächlich entstanden ist. Aber der Film ist wirklich sehenswert. Leider ist es fast unmöglich. Das haben wir als Festivalmacher und Macherinnen tatsächlich auch. Selbst wir können manche Filme nur einmal sehen. Die verschwinden dann komplett vom internationalen Filmmarkt. Das, was ich vorhin gesagt habe, dass wir Filme aus Asien, Afrika und Lateinamerika haben. Die sieht man dann wirklich nur entweder auf einem anderen Filmfest oder bei uns. Das geht jetzt gar nicht darum, dass wir die Werbetrommel so rühren müssen. Diese Filme haben häufig keine Chance, häufiger im Kino zu erscheinen. Es gibt jetzt keine DVD-Auswertung mehr. Das ist sehr bitter.
Natürlich hat das auch wahrscheinlich viel mit den Sprachfassungen zu tun. Wir zeigen ja alle Filme auch im Original. Viele haben aber nur englische Untertitel. In einer Stadt wie Berlin geht es ja immer noch. Aber wenn man sich mal andere Städte anguckt, läuft ja alles mal mindestens mit deutschen Untertiteln. Da haben sie es natürlich schwer. Durch das Internet ist natürlich einiges dann auch verfügbar, weil Filmemacherinnen und Filmmacher selbst bei YouTube reinstellen oder weil es über irgendwelche Bezahlkanäle verfügbar ist. Aber gerade so alte Filme sind dann einfach weg.
Aber die müssen ja noch im Besitz eines Filmverleihers sein, eines Filmrechteinhabers.
Ja, aber das ist eben – also ich weiß gar nicht zum Beispiel, diese ganzen alten Stummfilme oder so, an die kommt man ran. Aber es ist dann auch oft sehr teuer. Also wir sind ja auch ein kleines Festival. Und wenn man dann Screening-Fees von 500 oder mehr Euro zahlen muss oder eben auch bei solchen ganz alten Filmen ist das Format natürlich auch ein Problem. Wir spielen alles jetzt als DCP oder eben sonst als MOV-Datei. Das ist eben alles digital. Aber so ganz alte Filme kriegt man dann natürlich auch als 35mm-Kopien oder so was. Das ist natürlich auch noch ein Problem.
Also die drei genannten Elf-Teufel, dann König der Mittelstürmer und auch das große Spiel, die bekommt man tatsächlich beim Deutschen Filmmuseum in München.
Wahnsinn, und dass das noch nicht digitalisiert ist. Aber gut, hätte ich tatsächlich erwartet, dass man schon weiter ist innerhalb der Film und dann in dem Fall auch der Museumsbranche. Aber da wird es dann schon seine Gründe vergeben, warum das nicht so ist. Jetzt haben wir schon mal die Anfänge besprochen mit dem großen Ereignis, dass wir hier über die Zeit während des Zweiten Weltkrieges sprechen. Was hat sich denn nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg getan, Birger?
Da ist ein Film dann wirklich auch überaus bedeutend in der Fußballfilmgeschichte, wo es auch um den Zweiten Weltkrieg geht. Aber der Film ist von 1961, zwei Halbzeiten in der Hölle, wo es darum geht, das berühmte Kiever Todesspiel wird dort dargestellt. Also das Gefangene als Widerstandskämpfer gegen eine Auswahl des lokalen Wachpersonals, also deutsches Wachpersonal, ein Spiel austragen, wo es tatsächlich im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes um Leben und Tod geht. Und wo sich mehrere Historiker darum streiten, ob es tatsächlich in ähnlicher Form stattgefunden hat oder nicht. Also das Spiel und auch der Film enden so, dass die Gefangenen auf dem Platz gewinnen, aber dafür ihr Leben lassen müssen. Wir haben das Ganze vor zwölf Jahren, glaube ich, gezeigt. Wir haben das mit einem Dokumentarfilm begleitet und hatten auch noch einen Historiker zu Gast, der über die Vorfälle in Kiew gesprochen hat.
Und es geht eben in der Handlung darum, dass dieses Spiel zum Geburtstag von Adolf Hitler im Jahr 1944 in einem Straflage in der Ukraine stattfindet. Das ist quasi der Rahmen für diese Handlung. Aber wir haben jetzt ja eine sehr große Lücke, wenn wir von Filmen aus dem Jahr 1941 jetzt 20 Jahre weiterspringen. Natürlich liegt da diese große Zäsur des Krieges dazwischen. Es ist leicht nachvollziehbar, warum man sich nicht sofort wieder um Filme und Fußballfilme gekümmert hat. Findest du es trotzdem bemerkenswert, dass es so lange dauert, bis der nächste wichtige Film kommt? Oder passt das auch einfach zur generellen kulturellen Entwicklung in diesem Zeitraum?
Das Spannende ist, die Filme, auf die wir gestoßen sind, die in den 50er Jahren spielen, hatten tatsächlich in erster Linie Kinder und Jugendliche und auch Frauen im Mittelpunkt. Es gibt einen ganz bezaubernden Kinderfilm, der kleine Fimmel heißt der, von 1959 aus der DDR. Überaus sehenswerter Kinderfilm. Und ein Film aus der Tschechien, oder der damaligen Tschechoslowakei, ist ein Mädchen in der Fußballelf, wo eben eine Selbstverständlichkeit ist, für das Mädchen auf Fußball zu spielen. Der würde heute noch bis wahrscheinlich als modern gelten. Und die Konzentration war tatsächlich sehr stark darauf, wie es dann auch tatsächlich im deutschsprachigen Spielfilm war in der Nachkriegszeit, dass eher gute Laune in der Rolle spielte, Familienfilme im Mittelpunkt standen und gar nicht mehr so drauf geachtet worden ist, inwiefern jetzt tatsächlich Fußballgeschehnisse im Hintergrund stehen.
Ich meine, die Entwicklung des Fußballs verläuft dann natürlich auch in Teilen parallel. Die Besatzungsmächte Deutschlands waren diesen großen Versammlungen im Rahmen von Fußballspielen zunächst sehr kritisch gegenüber eingestellt, aus nachvollziehbaren Gründen. Dennoch hat sich der Fußball dann seinen Platz wiedererobert, auch sehr schnell als Refugium für die Bevölkerung. Aber der damit verbundene Nationalismus, den ja auch gerade Nazi-Deutschland für sich verwendet hat, da war der Fußball mehr als nur ein Spiel von elf Kameraden. Sondern da gab es eben auch noch eine nationalistische Bedeutung dahinter. Die schwang in diesem Nachkriegsfußball immer mit und dann auch in der Auseinandersetzung damit. Vielleicht kommt das auch daher. Und da spielt ja dann auch das sogenannte Wunder von Bern 1954 ja auch eine wichtige Rolle in beide Richtungen. Also zum einen, dass wir sind wieder wer, dass Deutschland durch diesen sportlichen Erfolg auf einmal auch gesamtgesellschaftlich sich anders wahrgenommen führt und auf der anderen Seite aber auch den unwidersprochenen Fakt oder unwidersprechbaren Fakt, dass auch dieser Sieg, dass da nicht nur Leute die falsche Strophe des Deutschlandliedes gesungen haben bei der Pokalübergabe, sondern dass sich auch der damalige DFB-Präsident in ganz wilde nationalistisch nicht nur angehauchte Reden verstiegen hat nach diesem Erfolg. Also der Fußball war nicht unbelastet in dieser Zeit, das möchte ich damit sagen.
Ja, spannend ist, dass der WM Gewinn 54 filmisch tatsächlich dann erst 50 Jahre später aufbereitet wurde. Also es gab natürlich viele Wochenmagazinberichte und ähnliches, also dokumentarische Darstellungen des Endspiels oder überhaupt der WM in der Schweiz, aber keine Filme sind daraus entstanden.
Was hältst du von der Theorie, dass das damit zusammenhängt, dass dieses Finale damals die Deutschen schon erlebt hatten, aber das sehr eng verknüpft war mit der Reportage von Herbert Zimmermann, mit der Radioreportage und deswegen sich lange kein Regisseur an eine filmische Umsetzung gewagt hat?
Ich glaube, dass die Reportage von Herbert Zimmermann so stark war, dass auch Sönke Wartmann nicht drumherum kam, die mit einzubauen. Herbert Zimmermann spielt dramaturgisch eine große Rolle in seinem Spielfilm, sodass man sich das sehr gut vorstellen kann. Aber es war eh nicht so einfach, die Leute damals eine visuelle Aufbereitung zu haben. Es gab ja noch wenige hunderttausend Menschen, die Fernsehbildschirme zu Hause hatten. Und ich glaube, dass diese Radioreportage auch eine Einmaligkeit hatte und nachklang. Von daher finde ich die These gar nicht abwegig.
Aber es ist ja auch oft so, dass eben dann so eine Auseinandersetzung dann nicht unmittelbar stattfindet, sondern eben viel später und auch eine neue Generation irgendwie dann das nochmal als interessant erachtet. Weil ein Dokumentarfilm ist natürlich was anderes, aber ein Spielfilm ist ja nochmal eine ganz neue Herangehensweise wieder an die Ereignisse, die da stattfanden.
Ja, vielleicht muss das auch so sein, damit diejenigen, die es damals noch live erlebt haben, das quasi wieder vergessen und der Spielfilm sich auch an ein Publikum richten kann, was zwar davon gehört hat, es aber zum ersten Mal dann in eigenen Bildern vor sich sieht. Also ich habe gerade zum Beispiel darüber nachgedacht, würde ich jetzt als Filmemacher die Abstiegskonferenz 99 mit Günther Koch in Nürnberg, bei dem Eintracht Frankfurt sich ja mit dem 5.1 rettet, würde ich das jetzt filmisch umsetzen, wo wir ja auch so eine herausragende Radio-Reportage haben. Und die Frage ist, könnte man jetzt dieses Ereignis, an das sich so viele aktuell noch erinnern, eigentlich ohne diese Radio-Reportage erzählen, oder müsste man da nicht einen ähnlichen Weg gehen wie beim Wunder von Bern? Und wahrscheinlich hängt das auch mit der kollektiven Erinnerung daran zusammen. Und dass die Leute das eben in den Ohren bzw. vor Augen haben, wie das damals gelaufen ist. Und deswegen wagt man sich da im direkten Nachgang zu so Ereignissen vielleicht als Filmemacher auch nicht so leicht ran.
Ich glaube, bei dem Spiel wäre es gar nicht möglich, weil man da diesen Satz hören würde. Das hat er sich doch ausgedacht. So unglaublich, dass man vielleicht da doch nostalgischer bleiben sollte und Günter Koch im Ohr behalten.
Das ja sowieso. Vor allem jetzt, wo sich zum 20. Mal Jährt und ja am 34. Spieltag der SC Freiburg auch den 1. FC Nürnberg zu Hause empfängt. Das wird vermutlich auch kein direkter Zuversand. Ich vermute, wir werden von dieser Reportage rund um diesen Mai-Termin dann noch einiges hören in diversen Fußballmedien. Aber jetzt haben wir ja einen großen Sprung gemacht. Wir waren ja eigentlich bei zwei Halbzeiten in der Hölle aus dem Jahr 1961. Birger, welcher Fußballfilm ist denn im Nachgang zu diesem Film noch aus deiner Sicht wichtig?
Ja, um über Dekaden zu sprechen, die 60er und Anfangs-70er spielten, da waren tatsächlich Spieler-Portraits die Filme, die für herausragende Ereignisse gesorgt haben. Einer heißt Garincha Allegria de Pozo, also wirklich über einen der wohl fünf besten Spieler aller Zeiten. Ich habe Ihnen das gestern noch gesagt, dass mein Opa immer schwer amüsiert berichtet hat, dass Garincha sowohl ein X als auch ein O-Bein hatte. Und dieses Portrait ist wirklich sehr gelungen, ist ein tolles Zeitgemälde, was die Fußballbegeisterung rund um die Spieler Garincha und Pelé angeht in den 60ern. Ein toller Schwarz-Weiß-Film und dann eben der vorhin schon genannte Fußball wie noch nie über George Best als Portrait 90-minütig bei seinem Spiel für Manchester United, damals gegen Coventry City. Das war dann alles so ein bisschen, also wo man sich heute auch noch überlegt, wer ist dafür ins Kino gegangen oder welche Kinos?
Ja, das wäre jetzt mal eine Frage gewesen, ja.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich die Frage und das waren wohl wirklich in erster Linie kleine Programmkinos in Großstädten, die sich vielleicht mal für eine Woche gewagt haben. Wir sind in der Recherche immer darauf gestoßen, dass, wenn dann die Filme tatsächlich auf einem Festival gelaufen sind, mit einer Ausstrahlung, kann man sagen, und dann später irgendwann mal als VHS-Kassette oder DVD auf den Markt gelandet sind.
Und jetzt war ja aber eine kurze Frage noch. Fußball wie noch nie war, so wie ich es jetzt hier lese, aber eine Produktion von einem deutschen Regisseur, Helmut Kostath.
Das war ein großer Film-Ästheten-Dokumentarfilmer, der zu der Zeit nicht dafür bekannt war, dass er Sportfilme gemacht hat. Es gab übrigens in der Zeit ein Sportfilmfestival in Oberhausen, das sogar mehrere Jahre bestand hatte, wo der Fußballfilm aber wirklich nur eine sehr geringe Rolle gespielt hat. Aber Helmut Kostath war eigentlich einer der wenigen Intellektuellen, du hast es vorhin über die 90er gesagt, und Anfang 2000 einer der wenigen Intellektuellen, der auch schon 1971 zu seiner Fußballliebe gestanden hat und die Möglichkeit hatte, best, der damals auch Popstar war, auf diese Art zu porträtieren.
Ja, aber es ist ja interessant, dass er sich keinen deutschen Spieler dafür ausgesucht hat, zeigt vielleicht dann auch die immer noch vorhandene Distanz zu den deutschen wichtigen Spielern. Da hat sich dann im Laufe der 70er einiges verändert.
Mit einem ziemlich gruseligen Film von Franz Beckenbauer, Libero 1973, wo er immer sagt, er schafft es nicht mehr, sich da ein paar Bilder anzugucken. Also es war wirklich wohl beschämend.
Also ein Spielfilm mit Franz Beckenbauer in der Hauptrolle, kann man sagen.
In der Hauptrolle, ja.
Über sich selbst, ja. Jedes Jahr diskutieren wir es wieder, ob wir mal die Reihe machen, Fußballer im Film. Aber wir haben immer so viele Einreichungen, dass es am Ende hinten rüberfällt. Aber irgendein Jahr müssen wir es mal schaffen, wirklich diese Reihe zu machen. Weil es gibt sehr viele Fußballer, die in Fußballfilmen, Spielfilmen auftreten. Als Fußballspieler, aber auch als ganz andere Personen.
Ihr könnt es ja verknüpfen mit dem Überthema Humor in Fußballfilmen, ungewollter, in Klammern, Humor in Fußballfilmen.
Aber der Libero ist bestimmt ein Leckerbissen. Der ist bis jetzt noch nicht bei uns gelaufen. So wie Ina das sagt, das ist wirklich eine Sache, die wir uns vornehmen. Geballter, da sind eben auch Filme dabei mit Paul Breitner in Potato Fist, Hadi Krüger und Ähnlichem.
Das ist natürlich auch interessant, dass das eher so die Filme sind, die in der breiten Masse Anklang finden, weil man sich darüber auch so gerne amüsieren kann. Viele von den Filmen, die du jetzt genannt hast, habe ich noch nicht gesehen, habe ich noch nichts von gehört. Lieberow habe ich jetzt gesehen und habe auch direkt wieder Erinnerungen daran, was ich da besonders lustig fand an diesem Film. Das sagt natürlich auch einiges aus, was beim Publikum dann verfängt und welche Filme es vielleicht etwas schwieriger haben, auch wenn sie viel besser gemacht sind.
Aber es ist auch eine absolute Rarität. Wie, wenn Schwarzenbeck kommt? Der Film ist von Werner Encke, der nicht Schummel-Liebling gedreht hat Ende der 60er. Das tolle ist, dass Katja Schwarzenbeck, Vorstopper der WM-Mannschaft 1974, selbst mit spielt in dem Film als Postbote und auch die einzige und letzte Szene des Films hat. Er trägt nämlich einen Brief aus und der ganze Film heißt, wie, wenn Schwarzenbeck kommt. Also es ist schon wirklich großartig, wie manche Regisseure dann eben auch ihre Fußballbegeisterung zumindest ein bisschen unterbringen können.
Aber das heißt, der Fußball spielt darüber hinaus keine Rolle in diesem Film?
Der spielt überhaupt keine Rolle. Und ich denke, wenn da Fußballfans drin gelandet sind, um den Schwarzenbeck zu sehen, die dann äußerst enttäuscht gewesen sind, zumindest 89 Minuten lang.
Ja gut, das ist ja wie die Angst des Tormanns beim FM. Da wurde ja auch tatsächlich verfilmt 1971. Das ist ja ganz ähnlich. Da geht es ja auch nicht um den Tormann eigentlich.
Hast du ihn gesehen damals?
Den Film habe ich nicht gesehen, aber weil ich auch meine Probleme mit der Rezeption des Buches hatte, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, also der Film beginnt mit einer Fußballszene. Das ist eigentlich genau umgekehrt zu dem, was ich eben gerade gesagt habe. Also die ersten zwei Minuten sind dort Fußball zu sehen und dann spielt es auch.
Genau, und der Buch ist ja genau umgedreht. Da geht es die ersten, was weiß ich wie viele Seiten, gar nicht um Fußball. Und ganz am Schluss kommt ein Fußballmotiv, das ist dann auch titelgebend. Und daraufhin haben alle, viele auch, die da gar nicht reingeguckt haben, in das Buch dann immer geglaubt. Das wäre das erste richtig literarische Werk aus dem deutschsprachigen Raum, was sich mit Fußball befasst. Aber wir wollen ja nicht über die Seitenstränge des Fußballfilms sprechen, sondern über die Hauptadern. Wen würdest du denn nach dem Libero, diesem unvergessenen Meister, weisen?
Da würde ich schon sagen, dass ein Film, der wirklich für Furore gesorgt hat zu der Zeit, unbedingt genannt werden muss, von John Huston Fluchte oder Sieg, ein sehr umstrittener Film Escape to Victory im Original. Dort hat John Huston es nämlich geschafft, mehrere Fußballer unterzubringen. Das waren Pelé, Bobby Moore, Adilis und Dana, der hervorragende polnische Spieler, haben mitgespielt. Es ist eine ähnliche Geschichte wie bei Zwei Halbzeit in der Hölle, dass Spieler versuchen, über ein Fußballspiel den Ausbruch zu starten aus einem deutschen Lager. Und es sind natürlich barbarische Ereignisse, die drum herum eine große Rolle spielen. Und umso grotesker ist eigentlich dieses Fußballspiel, das da mittendrin stattfindet, hat tatsächlich eine halbe Stunde Platz in dem Film. Auch Sylvester Stallone spielt beispielsweise den Torwart des gefangenen Teams. Und es lohnt sich, den Film zu gucken, aber man hat trotzdem ständig einen Zwiespalt in der Kritik. Also um zu sehen, wie das Ganze umgesetzt wurde. Es ist wirklich eine große Hollywood-Produktion, die auch ziemlich erfolgreich war.
Aus dem Jahr 1981, also wir sind jetzt schon in den 80ern tatsächlich. Als zwei Marksteine der Fußballfilmgeschichte – das ist ja schon interessant – haben wir einmal eben zwei Halbzeiten in der Hölle von 1961. Und 20 Jahre später nennst du mir als einen weiteren wichtigen Film der Film, der darauf basiert, der sich relativ eng daran orientiert hat. Und dann eben mit dieser völlig irren Star-Besetzung, mit Sylvester Stallone, Pelé und anderen bekannten Menschen, das nochmal anders aufarbeitet, aber nicht ganz unkritisch zu sehen ist.
Das ist auch das letzte Mal für eine lange Zeit, dass ein Spielfilm da noch eine Rolle spielt. Es gibt noch eine ganz wunderbare Jugendkomödie, die heißt Gregory's Girl, aus dem Jahr 1981 von Bill Forsythe, die z.B. Michael Kölmöhl, der Fußballunternehmer, der bei mehreren Vereinen ja geldgebend tätig war, und Weltkino-Betreiber des Kinounternehmen Leipzig, hat immer gesagt, das wäre für ihn der Grund gewesen, ins Filmgeschäft zu gehen. Der ist auch sehr lohnenswert, spielt in Schottland, ist eine kleine Liebesgeschichte, wo der Junge daran verzweifelt, dass das Mädchen besser Fußball spielt als er.
Das ist natürlich schlimm. Das ist ja ganz fürchterlich. Aber es ist ja auch ganz interessant, dass wir hier jetzt so langsam, zumindest bei den Beispielen, die wir uns jetzt hier herauspicken, dann auch einen Shift in der Themengebung sehen. Also wir sprechen zum einen, haben wir zwei große Filme, wo es darum geht, mit sportlichen Mitteln sollen Nazis besiegt oder nicht besiegt werden. Und das wird dann unterschiedlich interpretiert. Und jetzt haben wir aber aus dem gleichen Jahr wie Flucht oder Sieg eben diesen Film, den ich nicht gesehen habe, aber wo ich jetzt nach deiner Schilderung glaube, zu erkennen, da spielt der Fußball zwar eine motivgebende Rolle, aber eigentlich haben wir das, was du mir Ende der 20er so beschrieben hast, dass eine Liebesgeschichte im Fußballkontext stattfindet.
Jetzt hätte ich fast den wichtigsten vergessen. Und zwar aus dem Jahr 1974, Fünften der Knirps. Das ist ein Film, der so oft wie kein anderer beim 11mm Filmfestival auch gezeigt wurde. Wurde auch gekürt zum besten Fußballspielfilm aller Zeiten. Wer ihn nicht kennen sollte, was bedauerlich genug wäre, wenn es Hörerinnen und Hörer gibt deines Podcasts, die den Film noch nicht kennen.
Du sprichst sogar mit jemandem, der ihn noch nicht kennt. Ich schäme mich jetzt schon.
Das ist ja ein Ding. Es geht um einen kleinen schwedischen Jungen, der in der Nationalmannschaft landet, weil er so hoch talentiert ist. Das Tolle ist, er ist sieben Jahre jung und muss mit dem Starrum klarkommen.
Und er landet aber in der Männernationalmannschaft.
Das Tolle ist, dass es wirklich die originelle schwedische Nationalmannschaft ist, die sich in der Zeit für die WM 74 qualifizieren musste. Die Drehaufnahmen, die rund um diesen Spielfilm stattgefunden haben, standen immer in Zusammenhang mit den Qualifikationsspielen der schwedischen Nationalmannschaft. Das heißt, sie haben sich tatsächlich bereit erklärt, sich für die Filmaufnahmen aufzustellen, um dann hinterher ihre tatsächlichen Qualifikationsspiele zu spielen. Das war sehr erfolgreich. Schweden hat es dann auch geschafft zur WM 74 nach Deutschland. Der Film ist wirklich zauberhaft, weil die Spielszenen sind überaus amüsant gestaltet, wenn er dann beispielsweise die Abwehrreihe der russischen Mannschaft austanzt.
Die Gegner waren dann aber Statisten. Das waren jetzt nicht auch die wirklichen.
Die Gegner waren Statisten. Das haben sie nicht mit sich machen lassen. Aber das Tolle ist, so wie man das aus schwedischen Kinderfilmen kennt, dann doch auch eine sehr emanzimatorische Art und Weise, was Kinder machen dürfen. Und er kann eben auch den Schulunterricht schwänzen bzw. schläft ein in der Schule, weil er so viele Fußballtrainingen hat oder lange Reisen hinter sich. Und dann, um zum Schluss für sich zu entscheiden, ist es einfach toller, ein Kinderleben zu führen als ein Fußballstar zu sein und wieder mit den alten Kumpels zu spielen. Das ist ganz hervorragend. Der Junge ist später LKW-Fahrer geworden. Den haben wir versucht einzuladen. Hat leider nicht geklappt. Aber es gibt immer wieder die Anfragen, ob der Film nicht wieder bei uns gezeigt werden kann oder wo man ihn bekommen könnte.
Und ist es dann auch ein Film, der sich auch an Kinder richtet?
Wie man so sagt, zwischen 1986 und 1986. Also jeder, der sich da reinsetzt, wird seinen Spaß haben.
Okay, faszinierend. Ich komme auf meinen Pile of Shame, dass ich den noch nicht gesehen habe. Aber vielleicht gibt es ja mal einen Filmnachmittag. Vielleicht auch noch mit zwei zusätzlichen Zuschauerinnen aus meinem Haushalt. Das hört sich tatsächlich spannend an. Und diese Rahmengeschichte, dass da die echte schwedische Nationalmannschaft im Rahmen ihrer tatsächlich stattfindenden Qualifikationsspiele vorher noch Dreharbeiten zugelassen hat, das ist natürlich der Wahnsinn. Das setzt dem Ganzen ja nochmal die Krone auf. Toll. Ich müsste euch da was schenken, dass ihr euch hier die Zeit nehmt. Zusätzlich ja noch zu – also liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ihr seid gerade – keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich haben wir gerade die Stundenmarke passiert oder irgendwie so. Aber wir sind schon seit – meine Güte – jetzt fast drei Stunden hier schon am Ruck tun. Wir hatten noch ein paar technische Hickups im Vorfeld, im Zwischenfeld dieser Aufnahme. Also wenn, dann schulde ich euch etwas. Aber toll, dass ich jetzt auf jeden Fall weiß, was ich gucken kann. Und wenn das der Film ist, der bei euch auf dem Festival als bester Fußballfilm aller Zeiten ausgezeichnet wurde, dann muss das auch schnell jetzt geguckt werden. Das hört sich wirklich nach einem ganz bezaubernden Streifen an.
Ja, wir hatten ihn auch noch mal im Programm vor kurzem, weil es eine restaurierte Fassung jetzt gibt. Also es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall da rein zu gucken.
Fimpender Knirps, toll, aus dem Jahr 1974. Jetzt sind wir kurz zurückgesprungen, Birger, aus den 80ern in die Mitte der 70er. Wo würdest du gerne weitermachen? Was war für dich so das nächste Highlight?
Ich würde gerne weitermachen mit einem sogenannten Subgenre. Also es ist der Fanfilm, der natürlich auch eine Rolle spielt. Da gab es 1991 einen Film, der hieß Ultra. Das ist ein Film, der ein Wochenende zwei rivalisierende Fangruppen skizziert. Ich war früher als Fernsehzuschauer selten die Möglichkeit gehabt, Fußball in fiktionaler Form zu sehen. Das war ein Film, der mich wirklich umgehauen hat, aber negativ. Es sind Gewaltszenarien, die kaum aushaltbar waren. Ich hatte mich damals schon gewundert, dass da nicht erst ab 16 oder 18 freigegeben aufleuchtete, als der Film das erste Mal im Fernsehen gezeigt wurde.
Warte kurz, das würde mich noch interessieren. Es geht um ein Spiel zwischen AS. Rhoam und Juventus Turin und dann eben den gewalttätigen Auseinandersetzung zwischen Fans bei der Vereine. Basiert das auf Wahnereignissen, nimmt der Film für sich in Anspruch, einen Alltag in fiktiver Art zu beschreiben, den es so aber gibt? Oder wie hat sich der Film da positioniert? Weil wenn der so der Beginn dieser Filme ist – und ich weiß, dass da jetzt noch einige aus dieser Richtung kommen – würde mich das noch mal interessieren.
Ja, das ist so. Also er verzichtet eigentlich auf die Hintergründe. Er setzt komplett auf die Stärke der Authentizität, was die Fan-Auseinandersetzung angeht. Also es ist drum herum, welche Rolle die Vereine spielen oder so. Das wäre eigentlich auch auf viele andere internationale Fanszenen zu übertragen. Das Starke war an dem Film, dass er wirklich dann einige Leute, die in der Szene schon seit Jahren aktiv waren, wohl als Berater dabei waren, die Sprechchöre übersetzt haben. Es ist halt die Reise der Roma-Fans nach Turin, die dort eine Rolle spielt und dann die Auseinandersetzungen, die wirklich unmittelbar vor dem Spiel stattfinden. Es ist Stoff für Gewalt faszinierend, kann man sagen.
Okay, und dann bekommt er quasi seine Wucht daher, dass das zwar fiktive Personeneignisse sind, aber in einem Rahmen, der authentisch wirkt und es vielleicht auch in weiten Teilen ist. Und daher wirkt ja diese Brutalität nochmal anders. Deswegen habe ich eben gefragt, als wenn das jetzt etwas komplett ausgedachtes, brutales wäre, sondern dann hat das nochmal eine andere Wucht auf den Zuschauer und die Zuschauerin.
Das ist wirklich so, dass einige Filme sich rund um die Faszination Holigenismus aufbauen.
Kannst du mir erklären, warum? Warum ist das eigentlich so, dass uns Gewalt so sehr fasziniert, dass dann im Fußballfilm sah es eine Zeitlang sogar so aus, als wäre das das wichtigste Thema für Fußballfilme. Hat sich jetzt wieder ein bisschen verändert.
Doch, ich denke, Gewalt lässt sich ja immer gut verkaufen. Wenn wir uns jetzt aktuelle Fälle anschauen, wie die medial aufbereitet werden, sowohl in der Boulevard als auch in der seriösen Presse, ist ja schon so, dass Gewalterscheinungen rund um ein Fußballspiel tatsächlich auch dafür sorgen, dass diskutiert wird. Das ist wirklich, ich denke, auch so ein Hintergedanke gewesen, von Filmproduzenten zu sagen, Mensch, wir drehen diesen Film nicht nur für Leute, die in der Ultra- oder Hooligan-Szene sind, die sich den Film tatsächlich dann auch angucken. Das habe ich an einem ganz für mich irren Beispiel feststellen können, als wir 2004, zwei Jahre vor der WM, den Film Football Factory gezeigt haben, britische Fans und verschiedene Fan-Gruppen aus Berlin eingeladen haben, also sowohl von Union als auch von Hertha, als auch von BFC, Dynamo und TV-Fans. Es waren 200 Leute in einem Kinosaal und der Veranstalter, das war damals der British Council, gesagt, Mensch, können wir das überhaupt machen und wie viel Securitypersonal gibt es? Und wir haben das Ganze gemeinsam mit dem Fanprojekt gemacht und eben gesagt, ne, das geht schon gut, also wenn man zu dem Thema was Gemeinsames hat und hinterher eine Diskussion dazu führt, dann kann das ein erfolgreicher Abend werden. Und genauso war es dann, also wir hatten englische Fans vor Ort, die über den Film gesprochen haben. Auch dort gab es Leute, die beratend für die Filmemacher unterwegs waren und die Berliner Fans, egal welcher Couleur haben, haben hinterher sich sehr stark engagiert bei der Anschlussdiskussion. Also das ist schon ein Stoff, der erstmal Leute aus der Szene selbst fasziniert. Aber ich glaube auch, dass so ein gewisser Gewaltkick auch Cineasten berühren kann. Also nicht umsonst gibt es Filme mit starken Gewalt aus einer Andersetzung, die hohe Zuschauerzahlen haben.
Und Football Factory, aus welchem Jahr ist der nochmal? Das ist ja einer der bekanntesten Fußballfilme tatsächlich.
Ja, Football Factory ist aus dem Jahr 2004 Regie Nick Lowe.
Und was ist dazwischen passiert? Weil du hast ja schon gesagt, wir bewegen uns jetzt in diesem Subgenre des Fanfilms.
Ja, nicht nur des Fanfilms, sondern verschiedene Subgenres spielt eine Rolle. Also tatsächlich gab es, so wie man es in anderen Bereichen kennt, eine Menge Trash-Filme, die eigentlich gar nicht so genannt werden sollen. Aber das hat Ina am Anfang schon gesagt, es gibt eigentlich nichts, was es nicht gibt im Bereich. Fußballfilme von Komödie über Thriller zu Splatter. Es gibt Pornos, die eine Rolle spielen im Fußballbereich. Also das ist schon sehr weit gefächert. Und gerade in der Zeit ist man sehr erfolgreich, wenn man auf der Suche nach Trash-Filmen ist. Die 80er-Jahre haben auch dafür zu beigetragen, dass der Fußballfilm nicht so einen guten Ruf hat. Also beispielsweise Wundefußballfilme. Davon gibt es eine ganze Menge. Kung-Fu-Fußballfilme. Also das ist wirklich schon bizarr, was da alles zu entdecken ist.
Ja, man muss sich einiges antun, um die Perlen rauszufiltern.
Da bin ich ja froh, dass ich euch habe, dass ich mich nur auf die Perlen stürzen kann. Was ist denn dann so die nächste Perle? Also wir standen ja eigentlich im Jahr 1991 mit ultra blutiger Sonntag, wo du ja auch sehr eindrücklich dein biografisches Erlebnis dazu beschrieben hast, Birger. Was ist denn in dieser Phase noch wichtig an Fußballfilmen?
Da gibt es den zweiten Kinderklassiker, Le Ballon d'Or. Wir schmunzeln immer so ein bisschen bei den Einreichungen Jahr für Jahr, dass ein Themenbereich tatsächlich am stärksten bearbeitet wird inzwischen. Das ist ein junger, talentierter, afrikanischer Spieler, der versucht, auf dem europäischen Fußballmarkt Fuß zu fassen. Er wird meist sowohl ins Spielfilm als auch im Dokumentarfilm von Spielerberatern ausgenutzt. Nach kurzen, harten Monaten in Europa muss er wieder zurück nach Afrika. Die ganze Enttäuschung und auch diese ganze Brutalität, die dieser Spielermarkt-Business mit sich bringt, wird dargestellt. Und da gibt es verschiedene Einreichungen, die wir Jahr für Jahr sichten. Auch einige davon qualitativ gut, die wir gezeigt haben. Und der Ballon d'Or, da handelt es sich tatsächlich in einem Film von 1994 zum ersten Mal um diese Thematik. Ein Film, der aber von ganz hervorragenden Darstellern lebt. Und er war auch von der Geschichtserzählung ziemlich einmalig zu der Zeit. Dann 1997 – Fever Pitch – haben wir schon darüber gesprochen. Eine wunderbare Komödie mit dem sehr bekannten Colin Furze in der Hauptrolle. Auch das ist ziemlich selten, dass große Schauspieler und Schauspielerinnen sich in einen Fußballfilm wagen. In den 20er- 30er- 40er-Jahren war das schon eher üblich. Aber in der jetzigen Zeit und in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten war das nicht so stark.
Das hängt vielleicht auch damit zusammen, dass das Buch sehr erfolgreich war. Den Film habe ich tatsächlich noch nicht gesehen, muss ich jetzt mal gestehen. Die DVD kannst du mir dann mal schenken. Aber ich habe das Buch gelesen, aber den Film habe ich nie gesehen.
Mich hat da schon der deutsche Titel Ballfieber ein bisschen angestoßen.
Ja, deutsche Titel muss man einfach ignorieren.
Vielleicht wirklich. Aber hatte der damals auch an den Kinokassen großen Erfolg?
Ja, er hatte Erfolg. Er hatte keinen großen Erfolg, aber er hatte Erfolg. Er hatte mehrere hunderttausend Zuschauer in Großbritannien. Und er ist in Deutschland auf dem DVD-Markt ziemlich gut gelaufen.
Okay, interessant. Also da hat sich dann nach dem Buch, was ja auch so breitere Massen erreicht hat, auch der Film nochmal einen ähnlichen Weg eingeschlagen. Und du würdest sagen, er ist auch gut anzusehen, wenn man das Buch kennt. Wenn man das Buch nicht kennt, ist ein guter Umgang mit diesem Thema Fußball im Film.
Also eigentlich ist es der ideale Film, um Menschen zum ersten Mal einen Fußballfilm sehen zu lassen. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich durch die Romantik des Films, durch die Heiterkeit möglich einzusteigen und zu sagen, ah, so sind Fußballfans ja auch. Er ist ja Lehrer in seinem Beruf und wie er dann eben seinen Alltag an der Schule verbringt, aber auch wie er sich dann wandelt, also sein zweites Leben führt, sobald er mit seinem besten Kumpel zusammen im Wohnzimmer sitzt und sich Spiele anguckt oder auch im Stadion.
Also ein Einblick in die Feldziele. Ok, und man kann dadurch selbst verstanden werden, wenn man selbst Fußballfan ist, wenn man anderen Leuten diesen Film zeigt. Das nehme ich jetzt daraus mit. Sehr gut, den muss ich auf meine Visitenkarte drucken, diesen Film.
Ja, da kommt das wichtigste Mannschaftsportrait, das bis heute gedreht worden ist. Obwohl ich auch mit Vergnügen des Sommermärchen geguckt habe, 2006, das ist ja so ein bisschen ein umstrittener Film, aber den müsste ich mir tatsächlich mal wieder angucken. Aber mir hat er damals Spaß gemacht. Und das ist ein sehr interessantes Thema, ist Les yeux d'honnebleu von Stefan Meunier wirklich ein herausragendes Beispiel, wie man eine Equipe begleiten kann. Das ist wirklich zur WM 1998 gewesen, also die ganze Zeit, die ganze Begeisterung rum, und die französische Nationalmannschaft spielt eine Rolle. Aber auch die Spieler selbst werden hervorragend angesprochen, also sensibel begleitet mit der Kamera. Und trotzdem hat man das Gefühl, dass man in den vier Wochen ganz eng dabei war. Und ja, das ist sehr lohnenswert. Das war für uns einer der ersten richtig großen Höhepunkte, weil wir im zweiten Festivaljahr den Regisseur vor Ort hatten. Eine Sache, die wir uns damals wirklich noch gar nicht vorstellen können, dass solche Leute dann auch mal nach Berlin kommen, unser Festival zu besuchen.
Und wenn ich es gerade richtig sehe, dann ist es nach Garincha, den du vorhin erwähnt hast, der ja im Jahr 1962 rausgekommen ist, jetzt die erste Dokumentation, die jetzt wieder hier im Rahmen der Filme, die wir besprochen haben, stattfindet.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ganz enorm. Also die zehn besten Dokumentarfilme, um nochmal auf dieses Ranking einzugehen, die gewählt worden sind, da ist er tatsächlich der Älteste, erstaunlicherweise. Also die ganzen Dokumentarfilme, die wir als herausragend erachten, sind zwischen 2002 und 2017 entstanden. Also das ist schon ganz erstaunlich.
Ja, in der Phase, in der der Fußball immer mehr zu einer eigenen Welt wurde, in die man von außen nicht mehr so gut reingucken konnte. Vielleicht hat das damit einfach zu tun, dass einen dann deswegen das dann auch so fasziniert und gleichzeitig Dokumentarfilme nochmal einen anderen Ansatzpunkt haben, weil sie eben einen Einblick erlauben, den man sonst nicht hat.
Ja, tatsächlich war das der allererste Fußballfilm, den ich gesehen habe. Es war damals in Frankreich. Ich habe ihn mit einer französischen Synchronisation gesehen. Und ich war tatsächlich total geflasht, dass überhaupt Fußball im Kino vorkommt und dass auch eine Frau Fußball spielt. Generell auf der großen Leinwand auch noch gut Fußball spielt. Ich habe den Film jetzt tatsächlich nochmal gesehen, vor ein paar Tagen in Vorbereitung hier auf diese Sendung. Er hat mir immer noch ganz gut gefallen. Ich muss sagen, ich fand ihn so ein bisschen trashig im Nachgang. Vielleicht kurz etwas zum Inhalt des Films. Es geht um ein Mädchen, die in England groß wird mit indischen Eltern, die ihr das Fußballspielen verbieten. Sie befreundet sich eben mit einer Engländerin an. Die zwei gehen zusammen zu einer Mannschaft und spielen dann recht erfolgreich. Es kommt ein amerikanischer Talentscout, die Liebe spielt natürlich auch noch eine Rolle. Es waren eben zwei Frauen. Für mich war es wirklich ein Schlüsselerlebnis, gut Fußballspielende Frauen auf der Leinwand zu sehen und überhaupt Fußball auf der Leinwand zu sehen. Das war für mich das erste Mal, dass diese Leidenschaft für Fußball mit der Leidenschaft für Kino zusammenkam.
Das war ja auch damals ein sehr bekannter Film. Nicht nur durch die Referenz an David Beckham, der halt rund um die Jahrtausendwende einer der Fußballstars war. Der hatte ja auch wirklich einen großen Anklang im Publikum, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Ja, ich habe auch gestern tatsächlich noch mal so ein bisschen recherchiert. Also der hat, glaube ich, wahnsinnig gut eingespielt weltweit. Also einer der am meisten besuchtesten Kinofilme zum Thema Fußball bis jetzt immer noch. Also hat mit die meisten Einnahmen eingespielt. Und natürlich Keira Knightley hat danach natürlich auch eine steile Karriere hingelegt. Die spielte die Freundin.
Und du hast jetzt gerade schon angedeutet, du hast den Film jetzt noch mal im Jahr 2019 angeguckt. Der ist ja jetzt schon 17 Jahre alt. Du hast gesagt, in einigen Stellen kam er dir ein bisschen trashig vor. Aber findest du, das Thema Fußball wird da auch auf eine nachhaltige Art und Weise bearbeitet, sodass es sich auch lohnt, ihn jetzt noch anzugucken?
Total. Also ich wollte jetzt gar nicht sagen, dass der Film nicht gut ist, sondern ich war so begeistert davon damals und hatte ihn auch so in meiner Erinnerung. Und so ist es ja manchmal, wenn man dann nochmal was anschaut, Jahre später. Also ich fand, dass es zum Teil echt nicht so gut gespielt war. Also jetzt nicht von den Hauptdarstellerinnen, aber gerade so von Nebendarstellern und Darstellerinnen, dass es so ein bisschen übertrieben gespielt ist einfach. Aber es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall. Und das ist auch ein Film, wo eben natürlich der Fußball gut eingebaut wird sozusagen. Weil eben der Fußball ist für die Protagonistin in dem Film eben einfach ein Mittel, sich zu befreien von ihrer Familie anzukommen in der englischen Gesellschaft. Und das wird total gut umgesetzt. Also lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, den zu gucken.
Ich finde das ganz wichtig, dass ihr jetzt nochmal gesagt habt, wie alt der Film auch schon ist. Inna, machst du gleich noch was dazu sagen, dass wir auch ein eigenes Kinder- und Jugendfilmfestival haben. Und wir fragen uns dann immer, ist der nicht schon zu oft gezeigt worden? Aber wenn man heute mal 10- 12- 14-jährige Mädchen und Jungs fragen würde, kennt ihr Kick It Like Beckham, würde man wahrscheinlich in Fragen der Augen gucken. Ich denke, es lohnt sich immer wieder, solche Filme neu wieder darzustellen.
Ja klar, gerade beim Kinder- und Jugendfestival ist es ja auch nochmal was anderes als beim Erwachsenen 11mm, beim großen 11mm-Festival, wo wir wirklich wahnsinnig viele neue Filme eingereicht bekommen jedes Jahr oder recherchieren. Beim Kinder- und Jugendfestival 11mm findet im September statt, auch hier in Berlin. Da fokussieren wir uns tatsächlich oft auf Filme, die auch schon mal gelaufen sind, weil es einfach gar nicht so viele Neuerscheinungen gibt und da wäre natürlich eigentlich es gut, so einen Film nochmal reinzunehmen.
Sehr gut, dann haben wir hier live und eher schon mal ein kleines Mosaiksteinchen des Minimeter-Programms geklärt. Das ist doch schön zu wissen. Wenn wir jetzt im Jahr 2002 sind, bei Kick It Like Backcam, dann sehe ich, dass da auch ein Die Helden von Bern-Film erschienen ist, der ein Animationsfilm war und das ist nicht das Wunder von Bern, der im Jahr darauf erschienen ist. Birger, darauf habe ich euch jetzt nicht vorbereitet, es ist jetzt eine Frage aus dem Blauen heraus. Aber kannst du mir zu diesem Film was erzählen, von dem hatte ich vorher noch nie was gehört?
Ja, das ist – wie heißt die Technik noch? Trick and Stop-Motion. Das sind Lego-Spieler, die tatsächlich das Spiel nachspielen. Mit dem Originalton von Herbert Zimmermann werden die fünf Tore gezeigt. Der prasselnde Regen spielt eine Rolle im Bankdorfstadion. Das ist eine ganz hervorragende Animation. Der Film macht viel Spaß.
Sehr gut. Was ist denn der nächste Langfilm, also ein Film mit längerer Laufzeit, der in euren Augen bedeutend ist?
In der ersten zweitausender Hälfte – wir haben über das Wunder von Bern selbst schon gesprochen – kam die bis jetzt größte Produktion aller Spielfilme auf den Markt Goal. Eine US-Produktion, Regisseur Danny Cannon, und zwar gleich als Trilogie. Das ist eine klassische Aufsteigergeschichte, hat viel Ähnlichkeit zu Rocky. Rocky Balboa heißt Santo Munez und transferiert wird aus einem latinamerikanischen Land hin nach Newcastle, dort bei Newcastle United spielt, und dann in Teil 2 oder 3, so weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr genau, dann seinen Weg weitermacht und nach Real Madrid geht. Der ist für ein sehr breites Publikum gemacht, auch hier eine dramatische Liebesgeschichte im Hintergrund, aber es geht auch um Drogenkonsum im Fußballbereich, es geht um Korruption, um gute und schlechte Deals, aber was der Film hat, oder alle drei Filme, ist eine wahnsinnig gute Kameratechnik.
Spannend. Es gibt auch viele Cameo-Auftritte, lese ich von David Beckham über Zidane, Raoul, Alan Shearer, da könnte man beliebig weitergehen. Da sieht man aber schon die Größe der Produktion von damals, und vielleicht hat das ja auch die eine oder andere Hörerin und der eine oder andere Hörer schon mitbekommen, selbst wenn er oder sie den Film nicht gesehen hat, gerade als damals der erste Teil veröffentlicht wurde. Das war im Jahr 2005 schon ein ganz schön großes Thema.
Dann möchte ich einen Film platzieren, den kennt niemand, aber es ist einer meiner Lieblingsfußballfilme. Der Film heißt Das Jahr, als meine Eltern im Urlaub waren. Er kommt aus Brasilien, aus dem Jahr 2006, ist wiederum ein Spielfilm. Die Geschichte dreht sich um einen kleinen Jungen, zehn Jahre alt, das Ganze spielt zur WM 1970 in Mexiko. Er ist Brasilianer, naturgemäß eben auch großer Fan der brasilianischen Nationalmannschaft. Seine Eltern sind Kommunisten, die in der Zeit der brasilianischen Militärdiktatur verfolgt und verhaftet werden. Das ist die Parallelgeschichte dazu, wenn der Junge am Fernsehschirm klebt und sich wohnt, wo seine Eltern geblieben sind und ihm gesagt wird, sie sind in den Urlaub gefahren. Dann bleibt er zu Hause bei seinem Großvater und guckt zusammen mit einer Gruppe von Studenten in einer Kneipe zusammen die brasilianischen Spiele. Das ist wahnsinnig anrührend. Wir haben vorhin schon über das Todesspiel in Kiev gesprochen, aber das ist ein weiteres Beispiel dafür, wie Fußball, Film und Politik zusammengebracht werden. Das ist ein Schwerpunkt, den wir letztes Jahr vielleicht in der Maxi noch etwas dazu sagen. Fußball, Film und Macht ist letztes Jahr unsere Überschrift des Jahresschwerpunktes.
Genau, wir haben zusammen mit der Kooperative Berlin, das sind Medienschaffende im weitesten Sinne. Die machen Podcasts, Filme zu politischen Themen. Auch mit denen zusammen haben wir einen Schwerpunkt gestrickt. Fußball und Macht, wo es eben um das Zusammenspiel von Fußball und Politik und Fußball und Macht auch ging. Zum Beispiel auch unser Eröffnungsfilm vom letzten Jahr, The Workers Cup, der sich mit dem Bau der WM-Stadion in Katar beschäftigt, bzw. viel mehr mit den Arbeitern, die da beteiligt sind und die wiederum sich so ein eigenes Fußballturnier organisieren. Aber es geht natürlich viel um die Arbeitsbedingungen, um die Lebensbedingungen der Menschen dort. Und wir haben zusammen mit der Kooperative dann auch eine Podcastreihe gemacht. Aber die waren ja auch bei dir zu Gast schon im Rasenfunk.
Genau, aber wir können sehr gerne nochmal auf sie hinbeisen.
Fußball macht sehr viel. Genau, die haben eben Gesprächsrunden zu den verschiedenen Filmen geführt, die alle auch noch online verfügbar sind.
Sehr spannendes Thema, Fußballpolitik.
Auf jeden Fall. Und nicht endend. Wir haben auch in diesem Jahr wieder einige Produktionen zu dem Thema, die herausragend sind. 2008 ist das Jahr zweier toller Dokumentarfilme. Ein ganz großer und ein ganz kleiner. Die Hand Gottes, Maradona, Paa Kusturica. Eine Huldigung und Liebeserklärung, die fast ein bisschen zu fett ist. Vom Regisseur Emil Kusturica fehlt vielleicht auch der kritische Blick auf den Protagonisten Diego Maradona. Aber es ist ja wirklich so eine Schildernde-Gestalt, dass man fasziniert ist, also zu sehen, was seine Anhänger und Anhängerinnen für einen Kult rund um ihn betreiben. Aber eben auch, er hat da schon nicht mehr seine beste Zeit. Es steht schwer übergewichtig als Interviewpartner zur Verfügung und blickt gemeinsam mit dem Regisseur auf die Höhepunkte seines Lebens und auch seines Fußballerlebens natürlich zurück. Es ist ein Film zum Eintauchen und hat viele Menschen begeistert. Er hat bei uns das Festival gewonnen und Imme Kostorica hat tatsächlich auch unseren Pokal, die Goldene Elf, bei sich zu Hause zu stehen.
Das ist doch schön. Dann hat er neben Maradona, ist er jetzt hoffentlich noch Fan des 11mm-Fußballfilmfestivals. Das ist die dicke Dokumentation, was ist die unbekannte?
Die andere Dokumentation ist in Berlin weltbekannt, aber ansonsten darüber hinaus wohl eher nicht. Das ist Football Undercover, ein Film über ein Länderspiel Kreuzberg gegen Iran. Also junge Frauen aus Kreuzberg, die hier im Spielbetrieb waren und in der Bezirksliga gespielt haben, hatten die Idee und interkulturell aufgestellt sind. Ich glaube, 16 Spielerinnen aus neun Nationen hatten die Idee, ein Spiel mit einer iranischen Mannschaft auszutragen. Das Ganze wurde geleitet. Die Idee entstand durch zwei Zwillinge, die dort in der Mannschaft gespielt haben, die dann zugleich für Regie und Schnitt des Films zuständig waren, Marlene und Valerie Aßmann. Die es geschafft haben, bei allen diplomatischen Schwierigkeiten ein Freundschaftsspiel in Teheran auszutragen. Das Tolle ist, man kann diese Mannschaft auf dieser Reise begleiten und man darf da hinblicken, wo sonst niemand hinblicken darf, weil es beispielsweise den iranischen Männern komplett verboten war, das Spiel zu begleiten, also dazu zu gucken, aber man geht auch zu den Spielerinnen nach Hause und bekommt ganz viel vom iranischen Privatleben mit. Es ist ein Herzensprojekt gewesen und ein Film, der uns alle damals sehr begeistert hat. Ja, dann kommen wir eigentlich schon in die Zehnerjahre. Wieder ein Film, der es geschafft hat, sehr bekannt zu werden, war Looking for Eric. Es liegt natürlich daran, dass einerseits Eric tatsächlich Eric Cantona war, als Nebendarsteller, aber gleichzeitig mit einer ungeheuren wichtigen Funktion in dem Film, um einem gescheiterten Arbeiter und unglücklichen Fußballfan viel Selbstbewusstsein zu geben, Empowerment zu geben, taucht Eric Cantona als Figur auf, die eigentlich imaginär ist, aber für den Protagonisten eine große Rolle spielt. Ken Loach ist ein Mann, der komplett Fußball begeistert ist, er ist einer der wichtigsten Regisseure der letzten Jahrzehnte, kann man sagen, europäischen Regisseure, meist mit sozialkritischen Themen. Er hat in der Tat fünf Fußballfilme gedreht. Wir versuchen, Jahr für Jahr ihn für eine Hommage zu gewinnen. Mittlerweile ist er 83 und auch nicht mehr so reisefreudig. Aber er weiß von dem Festival und ich glaube, das wäre so etwas wie der Schirmherr für das Ganze. Ein erfolgreicher Spielfilm, der auch in Deutschland über 100.000 Zuschauer hatte, das ist schon eine ganze Menge und in Großbritannien sehr erfolgreich war. 2009, der wohl neben Film der Knirps beste Fußballspielfilm, so ist er ebenfalls bei uns gewertet worden, auf Platz zwei gelandet, damals The Damned United über den Trainer Brian Clubs, das habe ich vorher schon kurz angesprochen. Und dann gibt es wiederum eine Dokumentation, die wir noch sehr empfehlen können, The Other Chelsea heißt der Mann, ein Berliner Filmemacher, der über einen Oligarchen aus der Ukraine berichtet in diesem Dokumentarfilm. Und ja, rund um Schachtjoa Donets zwei Spielzeiten des Vereins begleitet und inzwischen schon weit, weit zurück liegt, weil es damals noch in der friedlichen Ukraine stattgefunden hat. Ja, überaus gelungen.
Und das heißt, The Damned United blickt ja zurück und ist dann ein Spielfilm und das andere ist jetzt eine Dokumentation oder?
Ja, das ist eine Dokumentation.
Okay, spannend zu hören. Und ab jetzt werden es richtig viele Filme langsam, die man so pro Jahr sichten kann, oder?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich so. Man kann sagen, das Jahr 2010, wenn man so zurückguckt, war das erste Jahr, wo wir es geschafft haben, das Festival, oder hätten es machen können, wollen wir mal so in der Form sprechen, nur von Einreichungen das Festival zu gestalten. Vorher mussten wir selbst immer recherchieren, beziehungsweise so schön, wie du unterstützt wirst, wurden auch wir immer unterstützt von Menschen, die irgendwo auf der Welt einen Fußballfilm gesehen haben und gesagt haben, Mensch, wäre das nicht was für euch, und uns den Tipp geschickt haben, wir mussten dann gucken, wer ist der Filmverleiher dazu, die Produktion. Aber seitdem, so wie Ina das vorhin gesagt hat, wir sind jetzt bei 250 eingereichten Filme gelandet, und das ist schon auch was Tolles, wenn man die Qual der Wahl hat, um so ein Filmprogramm zusammenzustellen.
Und ist ja auch so ein bisschen dann stellvertretend, also ihr seid ja dann mit eurem Festival der Seismograf dafür, welche Rolle Fußball im Film spielt. Und dann können wir eben so 2010 als die Marke ansetzen, wo man sagen kann, okay, ab jetzt wird es richtig viel, der Output ist sehr groß, es gibt ein reichhaltigeres Angebot als in den Jahren davor. Es wurde eben immer mehr. Und welche Filme würdet ihr dann gerne herausheben wollen ab 2010? Jetzt wird es ja dann richtig schwierig. Vorher war es ja einfach, wenn wir über 1927 sprechen, ja, das waren halt auch die wenigen Filme, die jetzt noch bekannt sind, die sich damals mit dem Thema Fußball auseinandergesetzt haben. Jetzt dürfte es ja schon kniffliger werden, einige herauszugreifen.
Das ist tatsächlich so. Also da kommen wirklich so die persönlichen Highlights dann dazu. Also Filme, mit denen man rund um das Festival besondere Erinnerungen hat, wo ich jetzt gar nicht mehr sagen würde, das war der Film des Jahres oder so, weil er qualitativ so herausragend war. Aber ein Highlight war auf jeden Fall ein Amateurfilm, nämlich der Film von Sepp Maier über die WM 1990. Also Sepp Maier hat damals als Torwarttrainer eine Kamera dabei gehabt und hat die spätere Weltmeistermannschaft begleitet und hat dieses Videomaterial bei sich zu Hause gehabt. Und dann passiert wirklich die unglaubliche Geschichte, dass ich all meinen Mut zusammengenommen habe, bei ihm angerufen habe und gefragt habe, ob es nicht möglich wäre, diesen Film im Kino zu zeigen. Ob es denn überhaupt ein richtiger Film wäre. Und dann ist er mit mir am Telefon in der Hand durch seine Wohnstube und urig kommentiert, was er alles schon so gemacht hat. Er hat gesagt, ja, hier stehen sie ja, die können es haben. Und dann haben wir eben von ihm alle Rechte bekommen, diese Filmaufnahmen zu zeigen. Und das war wirklich ein absoluter Hype, der dann stattgefunden hat. Weil das Kino war mehrfach ausverkauft, weil so viele Leute diesen Film sehen wollten. Sepp Maier ist selbst gekommen, viele Kollegen aus dem Profi-Fußball waren da zu Gast. Herbert Zimmermann haben wir als Moderator gewinnen können für den Abend. Und das ist natürlich eine Sache, wo ich jetzt immer noch sagen würde, gut, das war nicht der beste Fußballfilm der letzten zehn Jahre. Aber das war ein unglaubliches Ereignis.
Aber er ist nirgendwo erschienen. Also das sind weiter Privataufnahmen von ihm und den kann man jetzt nicht nachträglich noch irgendwo sehen.
Nee, der ist nicht erschienen, weil die rechte Lage so schräg ist. Also man müsste eigentlich jeden einzelnen Spieler fragen, ob er in dem Film gezeigt werden darf. Und Sepp Maier war ja nun auch eine Kante und konnte nicht mit jedem gut. Also das ist das, was dahinter stand. Ich frage jetzt nicht jeden einzelnen ab, ob ich da seine OK kriege oder nicht.
Das ist ja tragisch. Das heißt, diese Aufnahmen – also ein Teil davon kann ich mich erinnern, unter anderem die Feierlichkeiten in der Kabine. Die hat man auch später noch hin und wieder, gibt es da Schnipse, die man sehen kann mit einem sehr wenig bekleideten Lothar Matthäus sozusagen. Und der Pokal, der später noch von vielen geküsst wird, ist einer Delikatenstelle seines Körpers angebracht. Aber das heißt, diese Schnipse, diese Aufnahmen, die werden sich nicht in unser kollektives Gedächtnis einbrennen können, weil es nicht verfügbar ist.
Leider nicht. Das gehört wirklich mit zum Appell, sich die fünf Tage im Jahr zu gönnen.
Das war jetzt, glaube ich, die beste Fremdung. In welchem Jahr war das mit dem Sammai-Appell?
Wir trauen jetzt schon in die Festivalgeschichte ein, aber das sind so Sachen, die großartig sind. Wir haben nämlich genauso in einem Jahr, das war vor fünf Jahren, Schätze gezeigt aus dem brasilianischen Fußball. Da gab es sowas, wie früher Vorfilme in den deutschen Kinos eine Rolle gespielt haben, was in der Wochenschau gelaufen ist. Gab es in Brasilien die Tradition, dass immer die besten Fußballszenen der Woche vor den Filmen auf die Leimer gebracht wurden. Das Kanal 100 hieß das Ganze. Wir haben dadurch, dass wir einen engen Bezug haben zu dem Leiter des Festivals in Rio, Kontakt bekommen zu den Produzenten dieser Wochenschauen und haben die besten Ausschnitte aus diesen Wochenschauen hier bei uns zeigen können. Das war wirklich auch grandios.
Dann lassen wir zurückkommen zu Filmen, die man sich auch jetzt noch zur Gemüte führen kann. Wir werden noch ganz viel Werbung für das 11mm-Fußballfilmfestival machen. Wer jetzt noch nicht Lust hat, dahin zu kommen, der ist sowieso selber schuld. Was gibt es denn noch an verfügbaren Filmen, die ihr gerne herausheben möchtet?
Möchtest du schon ein Lieblingsfilm von dir sagen, Ina, vielleicht aus der Zeit?
Ich wollte noch mal auf einen anderen Regisseur eingehen, weil du gesagt hast, wir überlegen immer, eine Retrospektive zu Ken Loach zu machen. Wir haben tatsächlich einmal eine Retrospektive zu einem Regisseur gemacht, der vielleicht nicht so bekannt ist. Johann Kramer heißt er und wir haben einen ganz großen Fan auch bei uns im Team, unser Kollege Christoph. Er ist ein niederländischer Regisseur, der sehr viele Werbefilme und Kurzfilme gemacht hat, aber eben auch drei Langfilme, von denen zumindest einer, auch mit der Goldenen Elf, mit dem Publikumspreis ausgezeichnet wurde, mal im Jahr 2005. Das ist der Film The Other Final. Und zwar ist es parallel zum WM-Finale Deutschland-Brasilien 2002. Auf der anderen Seite der Welt sind die beiden Teams gegeneinander angetreten, die ganz am Ende der FIFA-Weltrangliste stehen, nämlich Montserrat und Bhutan. Genau. Und im Himalaya treffen sie sich und spielen dieses andere Finale. Und es ist ein ganz, ganz toller Dokumentarfilm über dieses Spiel eben. Genau, den wollte ich jetzt nochmal aus dem Jahr 2005 auch.
Ich setze an, und zwar gibt es einen weiteren Regisseur, ähnlich wie Johann Kramer, der uns schon mit mehreren Werken Beglück hat. Das ist Aljosha Pause. Wir sind auf ihn gestoßen, weil er Dokumentationen gemacht hat über Randbereiche des Fußballs, nämlich Alkoholismus im Fußball und auch Homophobie im Fußball. Da hat er sehr sehenswerte Reportagen zugemacht. Die haben wir dann auch vorgestellt, Homophobie im Fußball. Das war für uns auch ein Begleitthema beim Festival 2010. Und dann hat er uns einen sehr schönen Dokumentarfilm geschenkt, kann man sagen, Tommy Tzisou aus dem Jahr 2011. Ein ganz besonderer Film und ein ganz besonderer Fußballer, der porträtiert wird, Thomas Bräuch, der sowohl bei Gladbach als auch bei Köln unter anderem gespielt hat, sich in allen Situationen vor die Kamera stellt. Also das heißt, wir sind sehr nah an seinem Privatleben, bekommen seine Trennung vor Augen geführt von seiner Freundin als auch die Ups und Downs in seiner Fußballerkarriere eine große Rolle spielen. Seine Selbstzweifel werden dokumentiert, aber dann eben auch das Happy End, nämlich dass er nach Australien wechselt, für Brisbane spielt und dort überaus erfolgreich nacheinander das Tor des Jahres schießt, Fußballer des Jahres wird Meister, und heute, ich habe ihn vor kurzer Zeit widersprechen können, ein sehr glücklicher Mensch zu sein scheint. Und Aljosha hat es halt über einen längeren Zeitraum ihn begleitet. Der Film hatte bei uns Weltpremiere und ist auch heute noch sehenswert.
Absolut und tatsächlich Thomas Bräuch, ja Gast des zuletzt erschienenen Tribünengesprächs in Ausgabe 29, habe ich mit ihm gesprochen und hatte tatsächlich die Mammutaufgabe vor mir, angesichts dieser wirklich tollen Dokumentation, die ihn über so einen langen Zeitraum begleitet, sowohl neue Dinge mit ihm zu besprechen, als auch mich mit der Tiefe, die diese Dokumentation vorweisen konnte, irgendwie messen zu lassen. Ob das geklappt hat, das darf nicht ich beurteilen, das kann nur jeder Hörerin und jeder Hörer beurteilen, aber das ist jetzt eine interessante Synchronität, die ich aber auch erwartet hatte. Es ist eine ganz tolle Dokumentation – Tom meets Sisu. Und im letzten Tribünengespräch war eben Thomas Bräuch zu Gast. Und wir haben dann noch mal auf eine andere Art und Weise versucht, auch seine Karriere aufzuarbeiten. Ich hoffe, dass sich beides eigentlich ganz gut ergänzt. Zumindest wurde mir das jetzt rückgemeldet von vielen Hörern und Hörern, die auch die Dokumentation damals gesehen hatten und gesagt haben, super, das war jetzt noch mal so ein bisschen Teil 2 in Audioform, in akustischer Form.
Wir haben bis jetzt wenig über Trainer gesprochen, die auf der Leinbach gelandet sind. Da ist Aljosha Pause dann wieder zu nennen. Und zwar der Film heißt Trainer und porträtiert drei Männer, die im deutschen Profibereich auch schon eine Menge erlebt haben. Gar nicht so in der ersten Reihe stehen der Trainer gerade. Das ist einerseits der Stefan Schmidt gewesen, der unter anderem in der Zeit, als der Film läuft oder spielt, in Pallaborn Trainer war. Dann müssten wir beide Hälften der Trainer von Heidenheim, auch Schmidt, aber mit vornem Frank, glaube ich, ganz, ganz, ganz toller Typ, der in dem Film porträtiert wird. Und dann eben auch noch André Schubert, der ja nun wieder in Braunschweig harte Aufgabe vor sich hat. Alle drei werden durch viele Stationen begleitet. Und Ayosha schafft es, da doch sehr nahe ranzukommen und sehr intime Portraits für die Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer zu präsentieren. Also da sind wir, glaube ich, schon im Jahr 2014. Aber da ist noch ein weiterer Film zu nennen, der in dem Zeitraum sehr, sehr wichtig war, nämlich eine ganz großartige Kinderkomödie, die aber fast für Erwachsene noch besser geeignet ist. The Liverpool Goalie, ein norwegischer Film über einen kleinen Jungen, der nicht Fußball spielen kann, aber Fußball begeistert ist, Panini-Bilder sammelt, aber auch nicht. Er ist eine wunderbare Fußballerin und er darf als Ersatztorwart in einem entscheidenden Spiel mitspielen. Filme mit herben schwarzen Humor, sodass man Kindern bis zehn mal die Augen zuhalten muss. Aber...
Und sie ist eine wunderbare Fußballerin. Und er darf als Ersatztorwart in einem entscheidenden Spiel mitspielen.
Und da war das Schöne auch, dass wir versuchen ja wirklich, deswegen haben wir es inzwischen auch geschafft, dass wir wirklich sagen können, es ist ein Festival, nämlich zu jedem Film auch ein Regisseur oder ein Darsteller oder jemand, der bei dem Film mitgearbeitet hat, einzuladen. Und auch bei Liverpool Goalie war es so, dass die Produktion es geschafft hat, uns die Regisseurin und die beiden jungen Hauptdarsteller nach Berlin zu holen. Und das ist natürlich immer ganz besonders, wenn man dann hinterher noch eine Frage-Antwort-Runde hat und dementsprechend noch weiter eintauchen kann in das, was man vorher gesehen hat.
Ja, das sieht man mal. Von dem Film zum Beispiel hatte ich jetzt noch gar nichts gehört. Da muss ich mir jetzt alles nebenher zusammen googeln. Da sieht man mal. Also 2014 war ich definitiv schon tief in der Fußball-Blaze drin. Da hatte ich mich schon dafür entschieden, das zu probieren, mit dem Sportjournalisten da sein. Und dennoch flutschen einem solche Dinge einfach durch. Interessant.
Dafür hast du ja uns eingeladen.
Wirklich.
Ina bringt das auf den Punkt.
Ich habe noch einen Film aus dem Jahr 2016, der mir sehr gut gefallen hat, der auch unseren Preis gewonnen hat. Das ist der Film Zwei-Kämpfer. Es ist ein Dokumentarfilm über arbeitslose Fußballer. Also, das war etwas, was ich so auch noch nicht gesehen habe. Von einem jungen Berliner Regisseur, Mehdi Ben-Hadj Jilali. Und der politiert eben vier Spieler, glaube ich vor allen Dingen, die sich in so einem Camp für arbeitslose Fußballer fit halten. Und es geht eben darum, wie reagieren ihre Familien darauf? Wie können sie doch wieder einen Einstieg schaffen? Also, Niko Frommner ist vielleicht ein Begriff, der ist dabei. Christian Mikolajczak, die auch sehr offen eben darüber sprechen, wie die Situation ist. Das ist irgendwie so ein anderes Bild, was man mal bekommt von Profi-Fußballern. Und wie schnell das dann eben auch vorbei sein kann mit dem ganzen Hype und was man dann eigentlich so macht. Die waren auch zu Gast beim Festival. Also, es war eine sehr schöne Veranstaltung.
Ja, sehr interessantes Thema. Definitiv. Das kann ich auch wirklich jedem nur ans Herz legen, sich damit auch ein bisschen zu befassen. Das zeigt auch noch mal generell nicht nur der Bereich, was man eigentlich nach der Karriere macht, oder was man, wenn man aus unterschiedlichsten Gründen eine Pause in seiner Karriere hat und den Weg wieder zurückfinden möchte in den Profi-Fußball, sondern auch die Frage, was eigentlich jenseits von dem Profi-Fußball geht, den wir alle verfolgen. Nämlich erste Bundesliga, vielleicht noch ein bisschen zweite Bundesliga. Was passiert eigentlich darunter, weil das ganz andere Biografien sind, zum Teil auch andere Typen an Sportlern und weil da nämlich die eigentlichen Probleme anfangen, weil es da dann eher um Existenzen geht und um die Frage, was mache ich denn mit meinem restlichen Leben? Ich habe meinen Körper und meine nicht vorhandene Ausbildung dem Fußball gewidmet und jetzt sehe ich mich aber der Realität entgegengestellt, dass ich mit anderen Dingen meinen Lebensunterhalt finanzieren muss. Da liegen vielleicht die größeren Geschichten und die größeren Dramen, vielleicht aber auch Erfolgsgeschichten, als im Profifußball, der in seiner ganz eigenen Welt lebt, auch mit anderen Voraussetzungen für das weitere Leben.
Ja, total. Vor allem, wenn man dann wirklich erfolgreich ist, hat man ja eigentlich, wenn man halbwegs mit Geld umgehen kann, auch ausgesorgt. Aber wenn man eben so semi-erfolgreich war und das ist dann plötzlich zu Ende, dann steht man tatsächlich da. Und es war eben auch bei dem Film tatsächlich ein großes Thema, wie reagiert eigentlich das Umfeld plötzlich auf diese neue Situation.
Ja, sehr, sehr spannendes Thema. Sehr, sehr spannend. Jetzt sind wir schon im Jahr 2016. Das heißt, jetzt geht es um aktuellste Streifen. Weiß gar nicht, ob man das noch so sagt. Wen würdet ihr gerne da noch herausheben?
Also ich würde gerne noch den einzigen nicht-Dokumentarfilm, der bei uns gewonnen hat, herausheben. Leider auch ein Film, den man, ich weiß nicht wie noch sehen kann, höchstwahrscheinlich, wenn man Glück hat und in Italien in einem Unterhaltungselektronik-Kaufhaus unterwegs ist und sich eine alte DVD kauft. Es ist The Lost World Cup aus dem Jahr 2011, aber der ist dann tatsächlich erst 2014 ins Kino gekommen und die Geschichte ist vollkommen irre. Also es geht um die Weltmeisterschaft 1942, die keiner mehr so richtig in Erinnerung hat.
Vielleicht, weil es sie nicht gab.
Das weiß man nicht. Also es gibt auf jeden Fall einen hundertminütigen Film dazu, dass es sie gab. Und zwar das Endspielbestreiten Deutschland gegen Patagonien und die deutsche Mannschaft ist natürlich vollgestopft von irgendwelchen unerträglichen Nazis, aber einem sehr gut aussehenden Torwart, der sich in die Tochter des pathogenischen Trainers verliebt. Und das ist so die Randgeschichte, die, also Forscher sind auf eine Filmrolle gestoßen, weil, wie nennt man das, wenn man Saurier aus dem Boden holt?
Ausgrabungen.
Ausgrabungen, genau. Bei Ausgrabungen. Auf die Filmrolle gestoßen und können es einfach nicht fassen, dass tatsächlich, sowohl in der FIFA-Geschichte, es werden dann tatsächlich auch Joseph Blatter beispielsweise interviewt, der auch gesagt hat, er hätte viel zu spät davon erfahren, dass da zwischen 38 und 50 doch eine Weltmeisterschaft stattgefunden hat, nämlich die in Argentinien, Patagonien. Und der Film ist ganz zauberhaft gemacht. Man weiß ab der ersten Minute, dass es gefaked ist und trotzdem, also beispielsweise Gary Lineker erzählt darüber, wie sein Vater ihm davon immer schon erzählt hat, dass es so ein bedeutendes Spiel war, gut gegen böse und es ist ja eine ganz tolle Geschichte.
In dieser tollen Schnittstelle zwischen Dokumentation und Spielfilm, die man dann Mockumentary nennen kann, wenn man möchte, also ein fiktives Ereignis, wird im Stil einer Dokumentation dargestellt und schafft es dann tatsächlich im besten Fall, dass man sich am Ende des Films fragt, könnte das jetzt nicht doch so passiert sein? Ja, das stimmt. Da passieren einem auch manchmal Dinge, wo man sich denkt, ist das jetzt wirklich so zustande gekommen oder habe ich mir das gerade eingebildet? Aber so ist das manchmal im Leben. Ina, hast du noch was auf dem Zettel, was du gerne noch vorstellen wollen würdest?
Nö, ich glaube, ich würde eher zum aktuellen Programm übergehen, wenn Birger keine Best-of-Filme mehr zu nennen hat.
Ich bin auch an dem Punkt angelangt, dass wir 2019 eintauchen können.
Sehr gut. Ina, sag uns doch mal erst mal, wann findet denn eigentlich das 11mm-Fußballfilmfestival in Berlin statt?
Das 16. ist es und es findet statt vom 21. bis 25. März im Babylon-Kino in Berlin-Mitte. Ja genau, zum 16. Mal. Und wir haben Spiel- und Dokumentarfilme aus aller Welt, über 70 Filme insgesamt im premiären Rahmenprogramm, hoffentlich ein grün Rasen vor dem Kino.
Okay, das heißt, man kann sich schon in Kürze, wenn man das hier direkt nach der Ausstrahlung hört, überlegen, ob man da noch die Reise nach Berlin antreten will, oder wenn ihr Berlinerin oder Berliner seid, dann sollte das sowieso ab jetzt auf eurem Zettel spätestens stehen, da mal vorbeizugucken. Und was erwartet jetzt den geneigten Kinofan in diesen wenigen Tagen nächste Woche?
Also genau, wie gesagt, über 70 Filme haben wir immer, basteln wir Schwerpunkt rein. Manchmal legen wir die vorher fest und sagen, wir würden gerne mal was zu einem bestimmten Thema machen. So war es in diesem Jahr. Da haben wir gesagt, Frauen im Fußball ist unser Thema. Oft ergeben die sich aber auch im Rahmen der Sichtung, weil man plötzlich merkt, wir haben total viele, total gute Filme, die sich mit Regionalliga-Fußball befassen oder mit NRW vereinen. Wir hatten glaube ich schon mehrfach den Schwerpunkt Großbritannien, weil immer so viele starke Filme aus Großbritannien kommen. Aber in diesem Jahr war es anders. Wir haben uns eben vorher festgelegt und gesagt, wir möchten was zu Frauen im Fußball machen. Wir haben da eine Reihe zusammengestellt mit ungefähr zehn Filmen, ganz unterschiedlichster Art. Den schwedischen Film Football i Nöd och Lust habe ich vorhin schon ganz kurz vorgestellt. Das wird die Eröffnung sein der Reihe am Freitagabend, also dem 22. März ist es um 20.45 Uhr. Darum werden wir ein Gespräch stricken. Das Filmteam ist da, die Regisseurin und auch Protagonistinnen des Films. Aber sonst wird Frauenfußball in aller Welt gezeigt in dieser Reihe, in Spiel- und Dokumentarfilmen. Wir haben zum Beispiel einen Film aus dem Iran, Arak Esad, Cold Sweat ist der englische Titel. Da geht es um die Kapitänin des Frauen-Kleinfeld-Nationalteams, die mit ihrer Mannschaft zu einem Finale nach der Asienmeisterschaft reisen möchte und am Flughafen aufgehalten wird, weil ihr Ehemann oder ihr Getrennt verweigert hat ihr die Ausreise. Das ist ein gesellschaftskritischer Film über die Situation von Frauen im Iran, wo der Fußball dann auch wieder nur eine Randrolle spielt, aber für sie total wichtig ist und in dem Sinne natürlich auch ein Fußballfilm, weil er immer präsent ist, weil es natürlich um ihre Ausreise zu diesem Finale geht. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man da dauernd Fußballspielende Frauen sieht zum Beispiel. Wir haben noch einen Spielfilm im Programm Com des Garcons, der führt uns ins Frankreich Ende der 60er Jahre, wo eines der ersten Frauenteams über Haupt gegründet wird, weil Fußballspielen auch in den 60ern in Frankreich noch verboten war. Und in Reims kommen dann ein paar tollkühne Frauen auf die Idee, doch mal Fußball zu spielen und dieser Film begleitet sie dabei. Das ist ein Film, der läuft sogar schon so ein bisschen vor dem Festival, also man muss gar nicht noch bis zum Donnerstag warten. Der läuft schon am Montag den 18.3. im Citykino in Wedding. Es ist eine Kooperationsveranstaltung mit dem deutsch-französischen Jugendwerk und dem Centre Francais im Wedding. Genau, auch mit Gästen, zu denen kann Birger vielleicht was sagen. Der steckt mehr in den Gästen für diesen Abend drin.
Auch da ist das Frauenthema noch mal extra im Mittelpunkt und es sind Spielerinnen von Turbine Potsdam, zwei Spielerinnen, die vor Ort sind. Ich kann jetzt noch nicht mit den Namen glänzen, weil es noch nicht letztendlich bestätigt ist, vor allem auch was die französischen Gäste angeht. Aber das werden auch zwei weibliche Personen sein, die entweder in der Geschäftsleitung eines Französischen Fußball-Profi-Vereins sind und eine Spielerin aus Frankreich und darüber hinaus ist der Regisseur von Comme des Garçons vor Ort sowie die französische Botschafterin. Also es ist schon ziemlich hoch besetzt, aber der Film lohnt sich allemal. Es ist eine sehr heitere Komödie, aber eben auch mit einem Bezug zu der Geschichte des französischen Fußballs sehr ähnlich wie bei uns. Bis 1970 ist es in Frankreich nicht erlaubt für Frauen im Diggerbetrieb Fußball zu spielen und das Ganze wird auf eine ganz besondere Art nochmal vorgestellt.
Genau, dann umfasst diese Schwerpunktreihe eben auch noch ein paar Dokumentarfilme. Ich will nicht im Einzelnen jetzt auf alle eingehen, aber die Reihe entführt uns wirklich in alle Gegenden der Welt. Also wir sehen Frauen in Indien, auf Zanzibar, in Kabul, in Venezuela und was tatsächlich alle diese Filme zeigen, ist, was für eine starke Rolle der Fußball im Leben dieser Frauen spielt und wie der Fußball auch eine Befreiung ist für diese Frauen aus Armut oder natürlich auch aus sehr patriarchalen Gesellschaften.
Damit wissen wir, was uns jetzt bei diesem Filmfestival erwartet. Erklärt mir mal, Ina, fang du gerne mal an, wie läuft jetzt der Auswahlprozess ab? Ihr habt vorhin schon von den vielen Einreichungen gesprochen. Wie seid ihr da organisiert? Wer entscheidet letztlich, welcher Film dann gezeigt wird?
Also, wie haben wir vorhin schon gesagt, wir haben auch noch ein anderes Leben, wo wir hauptberuflich unterwegs sind. Und das ist tatsächlich bei allen so. Wir sind ein Kernteam von sechs bis acht Leuten, würde ich sagen. Wir organisieren uns sehr viel übers Internet. Also, wir haben so eine Google-Liste, in der alle Filme stehen und alle Sichtungslinks stehen. Das hat sich tatsächlich sehr verbessert in den letzten Jahren. Wir haben fast nur noch digitale Sichtungskopien. Vor zwei, drei Jahren sogar noch anders. Da hatten wir noch sehr viele DVDs, die wir dann irgendwie hin und her tauschen mussten. Aber jetzt haben wir einfach Links, wo jeder darauf zugreifen kann. Wir schreiben Bewertungen in diese Liste rein und wir versuchen uns eigentlich dann einmal in der Woche zu treffen, die Filme zu besprechen. Und die Regel ist sozusagen, dass wir immer sagen, es müssen eigentlich drei Leute den Film gesehen und bewertet haben. Und dann ist es eine gemeinschaftliche Entscheidung.
Das heißt aber, jeder der über 200 Filme wird von mindestens dreien aus dem Team von euch gesehen?
So wird es mal versucht. Also, wenn wir jetzt merken, zwei Leute haben ihn gesehen und sind total einer Meinung, dann ist es auch in Ordnung. Es sind auch nicht alles Langfilme, also unter den 250 sind auch Kurzfilme und mittellang Filme. Aber es gibt viel zu gucken.
Und vor allem das alles macht ihr ja dann in eurer Freizeit. Wie lange dauert denn dann dieser Auswahlprozess?
Also, wir starten so mit Filmanfragen, würde ich sagen, ab September vielleicht. Und dann so Ende des Jahres fangen wir an zu sichten. Also, viele nutzen eigentlich immer die Weihnachtspause so ein bisschen, um ganz viele Filme zu gucken. Und dann im Januar wird eigentlich jede freie Minute genutzt, um die Filme zu sichten und zu besprechen. Weil wir müssen so bis Mitte Februar ungefähr durch sein mit dem Auswahlprozess. Also, unsere Einreichungen dürfen bis Mitte Januar kommen. Aber wie gesagt, viele Filme fragen wir auch an und haben wir dann schon vorher. Und bis Mitte Februar müssen wir dann wirklich durch sein, weil dann müssen wir noch die Programmierung machen, die Filme zusagen und dann das Programmheft machen. Also, es ist dann auch schon ganz schnell März, wenn es Mitte Februar ist, es ist auch schon ganz schnell jetzt Mitte März, das heißt, es bleibt nicht viel Zeit, ja.
Und Birger, erklär mir mal ein bisschen die Hintergründe zum Fußballfilmfestival 11mm. Das wird in der Freizeit gemacht, wer steht da dahinter, wie kam es dazu und wie finanziert ihr dann die Filme? Wir haben ja vorhin schon mal kurz darüber gesprochen, wie teuer es sein kann, einen Film zu zeigen.
Ganz kurz auf die Geschichte eingehend, also wir haben 2002 hier in Prenzlauer Berg einen Verein gegründet, der sich Bode und Spiele e.V. nennt, Verein für Fußball und Kultur. Wo es in der Anfangsphase eigentlich darum ging, zusammen Fußball zu spielen, zusammen Fußball zu gucken und darüber hinaus zu denken, was kann man eigentlich noch rund um diesen Sport machen. Und da waren gleich mehrere Kulturaktivisten unterwegs, die verschiedene Ideen hatten. Der British Council spielte eine große Rolle, weil er schon sehr früh den Bode und Spiele als Partner im Vorfeld zur WM 2006 geladen hat zu mehreren Veranstaltungen und auch zu gemeinsamen Ideenwerkstätten. Und im Jahr 2003 ist dann die Idee entstanden, dieses Fußballfilmfestival zu machen, was auch möglich war, dadurch, dass der British Council sagte, gut, machen wir für euch, wir mieten ein Kino an. Unsere Bedingung ist, ihr zeigt bei diesem Festival nur britische Filme. Und das war eine Vorgabe, mit der wir sehr gut leben konnten, weil wir zuerst dachten, es gibt nur britische Filme. Das war dann schon mal klasse, dass wir wussten, Qualität stimmt, das Ganze ist durchfinanziert. Das war zuerst sehr bescheiden in einem Kleinkino im H-Markt hier in Berlin. Und wir hatten im ersten Jahr rund 400 Zuschauer. Aber was noch viel wichtiger war, war, dass die Zuschauer entzückt waren von dem, was sie da gesehen haben. Und wir von außen ganz viel Zuspruch bekommen haben. Auch Journalisten, die gesagt haben, Mensch, wollt ihr da nicht dran weiterarbeiten, dass es nicht einmalig bleibt. Und dann haben wir uns richtig, da waren wir auch so acht bis zehn Personen stark, auf die Reise gemacht, im doppelten Sinne. Also quer durch die Internetwelt, aber eben auch andere Festivals besucht, um zu gucken, ob es noch mehr Fußballfilme gibt. Und sind dann auch immer mehr gestoßen. Wir hatten von Anfang an den Anspruch, nicht nur die heute schon häufiger genannten Perlen aus der langen Fußballfilmgeschichte zu zeigen, sondern neue Erscheinungen auf die Bühne zu bringen. Und ja, da ist eben aus dieser spleenigen Idee, was ziemlich groß ist, entstanden. Für uns ist es etwas ganz Großes, für die, die immer noch dabei sind. Aber es ist halt wirklich, es ist an der Grenze. Also das, was du mit Rasenfunk auch erlebt hast in der Anfangszeit, man weiß nicht, wie man das Ganze finanzieren soll. Man kann trotzdem von dieser Sucht nicht lassen. Und steckt so viel Zeit und Leidenschaft rein und Arbeit, das ist schon ganz gewaltig. Und es ist halt immer größer geworden. Wir haben Anruf bekommen von dem Kino Babylon, die einen großen Saal haben und zwei weitere Säle, was für uns ziemlich klasse ist, sodass wir eben auch kleine independent Produktionen in den kleineren Sälen laufen lassen können und im großen Saal dann wirklich Festival spielen können, in dem wir Musik haben und Gäste, die wir auf die Bühne holen können und 400 Leute da Platz haben, das ist ganz toll. Und das war für uns dann auch nochmal ein richtiger Quantensprung. Und das Ganze musste aber eben auch finanziert werden. Es ist nicht möglich, dieses Festival alleine über die Zuschauer zu finanzieren, über die Eintrittsgraden. Und da sind wir sehr dankbar, möchte ich an dieser Stelle einfach nochmal sagen, dass die DFB Kulturstiftung uns in diesem Jahr zum zehnten Mal begleitet. Das sorgt dafür, dass wir eine Grundfinanzierung haben, heißt, dass wir schaffen, die Filme bezahlen zu können und auch die besagten Gäste einladen zu können. Alles noch in einem sehr bescheidenen Rahmen und so, wie es Ina vorhin schon auch gesagt hat, wir sind eigentlich alle ehrenamtlich unterwegs, können uns zum Schluss eine kleine Aufwandsentschädigung zahlen, aber ansonsten ist das schon ziemlich irre, was wir da machen.
Und dadurch, dass ein eingetragener Verein dahinter steht, ist ja auch klar, dass es keine gewinnorientierte Veranstaltung sein kann, vor allem, weil er ja nicht gemeinnützig im Sinne des DFBs oder der FIFA sei. Da wird das nochmal anders interpretiert. Sondern man kann eben bei euch auch sicher sein, dass wenn man dieses Festival unterstützt durch Besuch oder andere Dinge, dass man da auch jetzt einer guten Sache etwas beisteuert und nicht einem Kommerzdrang irgendwie noch neues Feuer verleiht, sondern das ist bei euch eben anders gelagert.
Wir können einen Aufruf starten, was uns Jahr für Jahr am meisten Schwierigkeiten bereitet, außer dem normalen Programmierungsbetrieb, den wir haben, und Sichtungsbetrieb ist, Schauspielerinnen und Schauspieler, Regisseure und Regisseurinnen zu gewinnen, die bei uns in der Jury sitzen. Wir setzen unsere Jury meistens so zusammen, dass die Hälfte aus dem Fußballbereich kommt, die andere eher aus dem Filmbereich, aber es ist kolossal schwierig, Menschen zu finden, die an dem Tag, das letzte Tag des Festivals vor Ort sind und mit voten, sozusagen für die besten Kurzfilme des Jahres und wenn deine Hörerinnen und Hörer eng befreundete Leute aus dem Bereich Film haben, dürfen sie sich gerne an uns finden und bis nächstes Jahr wird die Jurybank dann schon bereitgestellt.
Also ganz spontan fallen mir schon mal drei Leute ein, ich weiß, sie sind Schauspieler, zum Teil im Film, zum Teil im Theater und Fußball begeistert, denn sie betreiben Fußballpodcasts. Bei Doppel-6 gibt es Hendrix von Bölzingslöwen und beim Brennerpass gibt es Maximilian Nofker und Rüdiger Rudolf. Herzliche Grüße an der Stelle. Wenn ihr das jetzt hören könnt, wenn nicht, dann werdet ihr bald von mir eine Nachricht bekommen und dann werde ich mal Kontakt herstellen. Das könnt ihr doch tatsächlich…
Genau, vielleicht dann nochmal so ein bisschen zum aktuellen Programm. Also ich habe jetzt ja die eine Schwerpunktreihe Frauen im Fußball vorgestellt. Wir haben tatsächlich noch eine zweite Schwerpunktreihe in diesem Jahr. Das ist das Thema Serien, weil auch der Fußballfilm – oder ist ja dann eine Serie, nicht mehr ein klassischer Film – aber auch dort gibt es immer mehr Serien. Also es ist wirklich der Wahnsinn, wie viel in dem Bereich eigentlich auch meistens Dokumentarfilmserien produziert wird. Auf der Elf-Freunde war auch auf dem Cover Sunderland Till I Die eine sehr gute Serie von Netflix, die wir leider nicht zeigen können beim Festival, weil Netflix seine Serien nicht auf Festivals zeigen möchte. Aber wir haben ein paar andere tolle über Mannschaften, über Spieler und auch eine fiktive Serie, auch aus Schweden – nein, aus Norwegen kommt sie – über eine Frau, die ein Männerteam trainiert. Heimelbane heißt sie. Und dann das große Programm sind nationale und internationale Neuerscheinungen, also wirklich Fußballfilme aus den letzten zwei, drei Jahren, aus allen Ländern zu allen möglichen Themen, Spiele und Dokumentarfilme. Da ist wirklich für jeden und jede etwas dabei.
Das klingt alles so spannend, dass man sich gar nicht vorstellen kann, durch welche Kenfie ihr wahrscheinlich die letzten Jahre gehen musstet, um dieses Festival hinzustellen. Aber jeder, der sich kurz damit befasst und dann mal auch drüber nachdenkt, was es bedeutet, so etwas zu machen, der sieht dann doch, okay, das wird dann doch nicht so einfach sein. Birger, du hast vorhin erwähnt, dass es auch andere Fußballfilmfestivals gibt, die ihr in den Anfangszeiten dann besucht habt, um auch Einreichungen, neue Filme zu finden, euch inspirieren zu lassen. Wie verbreitet es es denn, so Filmfestivals mit dem Schwerpunkt, Fußball zu machen?
Nee, das ist ein Missverständnis. Also wir waren tatsächlich das erste Fußballfilmfestival und das nächste ist danach sechs Jahre später im Rio de Janeiro.
Ach, weltweit auch das erste.
Wir waren weltweit das erste, also kann man so mit viel Glück und Stolz sagen. Wir haben andere Festivals, also normale Filmfestivals besucht, wo dann auch mal beispielsweise, fällt mir jetzt ein, beim nordischen Filmfestival in Lübeck ein schwedischer Fußballfilm gezeigt wurde. Und dann haben wir eben gleich versucht, da Kontakt aufzunehmen und zu sagen, Mensch, habt ihr nicht Lust, den Film nächstes Jahr bei uns auch noch zu zeigen. Also das war die Reise, die wir gemacht haben. Es gibt mittlerweile 19 offizielle Fußballfilmfestivals weltweit. Und das geht wirklich über alle fünf Kontinente. Wir haben Festival in Kolumbien, Bogota, genauso wie in Beijing, in Sydney. Gibt es eins in Namibia, also da haben wir die anderen Kontinente. In Europa gibt es sowohl in Spanien als auch in der Schweiz sogar zwei mittlerweile. Basel, St. Gallen, Barcelona und Bilbao. Und das Schöne ist, wir hatten vor zwei Jahren hier ein Treffen aller Festivalmacher und Macherinnen. Und seitdem hat sich da auch so ein Freundeskreis aufgebaut, das wir natürlich wunderbar nutzen können. Das heißt, dass die lateinamerikanischen Festivaldirektoren uns ihre Tipps zuschicken, was gibt es Neues in Argentinien und in Chile. Und uns dann wiederum im März hier besuchen, um sich in erster Linie die europäischen Filme anzugucken, die sie sonst nicht sehen. Also, dass das Ganze gewachsen ist. Aber auch hier muss man sagen, es ist eine Randerscheinung, aber eine, die mit ganz viel Herz ausgefüllt wird. Es gibt kein Festival, das tatsächlich es schafft, jemanden hauptamtlich anzustellen, um das zu betreiben.
Das ist ja wirklich interessant und dass ihr weltweit die ersten wart, ist natürlich Wahnsinn. Herzlichen Glückwunsch dazu. Und wie stehen eurer Meinung nach die Chancen, dass sich dieses Festival auch mal aus dem Berliner Kontext löst? Ich glaube gerade schon, erkennt zu können, dass er dann die Frage doof ist, weil ihr das ja alles ehrenamtlich macht. Wann sollt ihr das auch noch in andere Städte bringen? Aber gäbe es dafür denn überhaupt die Möglichkeit, dass man jetzt sagen könnte, vielleicht hat ja sogar auch der eine oder andere Hörer oder Hörerin da draußen Lust, da mitzuhelfen, vielleicht sogar Kontakte, dann das Programm des Festivals auch an anderen Standorten verfügbar zu machen?
Also das Festivale war schon häufig auf Tour, wir werden häufig eingeladen, gerade so im Vorfeld von Europa- und Weltmeisterschaften. Jetzt haben wir im letzten Jahr zwei 11mm-Fußballfilme und Tourfestivals in Russland gehabt, in Rostov und Kazan. Wir waren in der Schweiz, Österreich, Ukraine, Polen, in Paris, in Rio de Janeiro, also das ist schon so, dass wir dann wirklich gebucht werden, für einige Tage dann ein Filmprogramm zusammenstellen und das häufig in Zusammenarbeit beispielsweise mit dem Auswärtigen Amt oder dem Goethe-Institut oder den jeweiligen Jugendwerken der Nation dann ausführen als Auftragsarbeit. Aber dass das Ganze etabliert werden kann, woanders, dazu bräuchte es tatsächlich den großen Finanziell. Der sagt, Mensch, das ist so eine irre Idee und da bauen wir drum herum noch was Gutes und dann schaffen wir es, dass zwei, drei, vier Leute von euch davon leben können und das auch eben tagtäglich machen.
Ja, ich wollte noch sagen, wir sind auch nicht nur in der Welt unterwegs, sondern tatsächlich auch manchmal in Deutschland, in anderen Städten. In Dortmund haben wir regelmäßig Filme gezeigt, im Deutschen Fußballmuseum schon. Oder in Mannheim fand mal so ein kleiner Ableger das Festival statt, aber das sind eben immer Einzelanfragen, bei denen wir dann auch gucken müssen, wie kriegen wir die eigentlich unter bei dem, was wir sonst alles noch so tun.
Ich habe jetzt mitbekommen, im Oktober gab es noch ein regionales Fußballfilmfestival. Das erste Fußballfilmfestival im Revierspiel Abdat-Dingen. Da konnte man dann unter anderem Being Mario, Götze und Ennards eine Zebra-Legende sehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr in Kontakt mit den Machern davon seid, das war auch glaube ich im Rahmen des Fußballmuseums alles aufgezogen. Gibt es Anhaltspunkte zu glauben, dass sowas jetzt vielleicht zunimmt, dass man, wenn man sich für Fußball auch in einem kulturellen Umfeld interessiert, mehr Angebote in Deutschland bekommt?
Also es gibt auf jeden Fall Bedarf, das kriegen wir mit durch unsere Arbeit, also wirklich die Kollegen aus den Lernzentren als auch in den Fanprojekten sagen, Mensch, das ist ein tolles Medium, um in Kontakt zu kommen, also jetzt auch rein vom pädagogischen Ansatz her, aber auch sonst gibt es im Aufglaub oder im Nachklang eines Festivals immer wieder Anfragen aus Bielefeld oder aus Passau oder sonst wo, man sagt immer Flensburg und Passau, ob es nicht möglich wäre, sowas in ihren Städten auch zu machen. Es wird tatsächlich ein bisschen konkreter, es gibt zwei Städte, wo wir überlegen sind, inwiefern wir das umsetzen könnten, das für drei bis fünf Tage zu machen, aber ja, Bedarf ist da und inzwischen ist auch viel Stoff da und da muss man einfach dazu sagen, wir haben in den vergangenen 16 Jahren hochgerechnet zwischen 1500 und 2000 Filme gesehen und die könnten überall auf anderen Festivals auftauchen, weil wir sagen können, da gibt es die Kontakte, wir haben den Kontakt zu den einzelnen Filme verleihen, wir wissen, welche Qualität die Filme haben, also das wäre so gesehen administrativ zu leisten.
Und kann man euch als Privatperson noch anders unterstützen, als dass man euch Schauspieler in die Jury setzt?
Also wie Birger schon gesagt hat, wir sind ja ein Verein Brot und Spiele e.V. Wir freuen uns immer über Mitstreiterinnen und Mitstreiter, die auch Lust haben, sich im Verein zu engagieren und dann eben auch mit Sichten beim Festival aushelfen. Also für dieses Jahr sind wir jetzt gut aufgestellt mit Helferinnen und Helfern. Aber so grundsätzlich freuen wir uns immer über Menschen, die genauso verrückt nach Fußball und Film oder Fußball und Kultur sind wie wir und einfach Lust haben, sich ab und zu mit uns zu treffen und an diesem Festival oder anderen Projekten zu stricken.
Darüber hinaus kann man wirklich sagen, verbunden mit deiner Frage, also wenn Personen in ihrem Umfeld beispielsweise Programmkino-Betreiber kennen oder Leute, die in kulturellen Institutionen arbeiten, Zugang zu Kinos haben, die dürfen sich gerne bei uns melden und dann kann man gucken, inwiefern wir es wirklich schaffen, dann 11mm on Tour zu schicken.
Das wäre wirklich was Feines, man kann euch auch folgen auf Twitter, mit den Ziffern 11mm und MM für Millimeter, ein sehr eingängiger Twitter-Handle. Generell sollte man so ein bisschen im Auge behalten, was ihr so alles macht, denn es ist bemerkenswert, so etwas über so eine lange Zeit aufrechtzuhalten, auch mit diesem Aufwand. Ihr habt das jetzt so ein bisschen, ich finde, fast schon kleiner geredet, als ihr hättet müssen. Es ist unglaublich, dass ihr das schafft, auf die Beine zu stellen und dass ihr dann noch Zeit habt, für ein langes Tribünengespräch, unmittelbar vor dem Festival. Und ich hatte es ja schon angedeutet, für uns war das Ganze jetzt auch länger als für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, durch so einige technische Ungereimtheiten, die wir da noch auflösen müssten. Also wirklich faszinierend. Ich kann an der Stelle dann auch sagen, dass bei diesem Fußballfilmfestival ich auch einen kleinen Part haben werde. Im Rahmen einer Podiumsdiskussion werde ich auch noch in der nächsten Schlusskonferenz drüber erzählen. Aber ehrlich gesagt, mich braucht es da als Argument nicht, um da hinzukommen. Die Argumente habt ihr jetzt schon vorher geliefert. Vielen Dank euch beiden. Ja, ich freue mich auch, euch dann wiederzusehen. Auch Brot und Spiele. Da machen wir noch mal was Eigenes dazu. Das ist sowieso ein interessantes Thema. Abschließend würde mich noch interessieren, wenn ihr euch etwas wünschen könntet, was sich im Bezug auf kulturellen Betrieb und Fußball in den nächsten fünf Jahren verändert. Habt ihr da konkrete Vorstellungen, Ina?
Also es hat, glaube ich, gar nicht nur mit Fußball und Kultur zu tun, sondern generell mit dem Kulturbetrieb, dass irgendwie die Bezahlung so ein bisschen besser wird und die finanzielle Ausstattung, also nicht nur die Honorare, sondern einfach auch so ein bisschen Planungssicherheit für all die Kulturschaffenden da draußen, die sehr viel von ihrem Enthusiasmus leben müssen und einfach auf fehlende Sicherheit haben und nicht wissen, wie findet das nächste Jahr statt. Da sind wir ja sogar noch ganz gut ausgestattet mit so einem Partner wie der DFB Kulturstiftung, wo man wirklich weiß, jährlich sind die eigentlich wieder dabei, aber grundsätzlich würde ich mir da so ein bisschen mehr Sicherheit und Akzeptanz auch wünschen für das, was ganz viele Leute mit ganz viel Herdspurt auf die Beine stellen in der Republik.
Ja, Birger?
Ich schließe mich an darüber hinaus, träume ich immer noch davon, dass die Sache, die so oft schon genannt wird, tatsächlich mal wahr wird, nämlich dass es eine neue Generation von Fußballfunktionären geben wird. Leider sind auch die, die jetzt 40 oder Mitte 40 sind, nicht großartig anders als die Vorgänger, sonst würde ich nämlich hoffen, dass diese Leute, die in Geschäftsleitung von Bundesliga- und Zweitliga-Vereinen sitzen, ein Verständnis dafür entwickeln, was Fußballkultur alles bedeutet und eben auch Dinge wie ein Fußballpodcast oder ein Fußballfilmfestival unterstützen und merken, was das Fandasein noch alles mit sich bringen kann und wie viel Kreativität gegeben ist rund um den Fußball. Wir wissen das alle, aber leider ist es in den Vereinsleitungen immer noch nicht angekommen und da wären eben auch die wirtschaftlichen Mittel, um sowas zu unterstützen.
Da kann man sich natürlich nur anschließen. Da sitzen wir drei aber ja auch in einem gemeinsamen Boot. Das habt ihr ja auch schon gerade umrissen. Ich danke euch beiden. Das war zum einen Birger Schmidt, der Leiter des 11mm-Fußballfilmfestivals in Berlin ist, ehrenamtlich und noch viele andere Dinge, tolle Dinge tut. Birger, vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Sehr gerne.
Das freut mich. Und herzlichen Dank auch an Ina Bargmann, die logischerweise auch beim 11mm-Fußballfilmfestival mitarbeitet. Ich habe das jetzt nur wiederholt, um diesen Namen häufig genug fallen gelassen zu haben, dass es mich allen Menschen einbrennt in den Gehirn. Ina, vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Ja, vielen Dank für die Einladung. Und wir freuen uns auf nächste Woche auf das Festival und auf deinen Besuch.
Das tue ich ebenso. Das wird ganz, ganz großartig, euch dann dort zu sehen. Und auch alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die das jetzt nach diesem Festival hören, nehmt euch das Thema an, schaut, was es da in eurer Gegend gibt, wie ihr vielleicht selber unterstützen könnt. Ich danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ich danke für alle Unterstützerinnen und Unterstützer. Und hoffe, dieses Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch hat euch gefallen. Lasst uns gerne Feedback da unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Bis bald mal wieder. Macht's gut, ciao.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.